[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well well well what do we have here
welcome to the dream
one of them little online shows kids
welcome
to fat man beyond i'm your host kevin
smith i'm the other guy mark bernard
he's also your host we're both your
[ __ ] hosts
get ready to hate us hate one guy
because he's cheery and likes everything
i hate the other guy because he's judgy
and has ideas
two great tastes that taste great
together meet jolly and judgey two guys
who
brought you by warner brothers
oh [ __ ] let me tell you something after
the other day i don't think i'm ever
getting any warner brothers [ __ ] work
anymore
i
i uh i did a comedy show where i talked
about the hbo max situation and the next
day or two i saw things like
smith eviscerates
butchers smith attacks
smith
so many aggro words and i went i was
like wow i must have been pretty [ __ ]
beside myself and then i went and
watched it back and i'm like
little clickbaity kids uh sloane did
newsday yeah they made it sound like i
was [ __ ] mad i was just like
i look i'm like everybody else why'd
they do this but
yeah it is crazy man the amount of like
smith
cuts to the bone and he [ __ ]
takes out warner brothers eyeballs and
[ __ ] eats them and [ __ ]
it was a
comedy show where i fellated a [ __ ]
microphone mark like
so like normal
yeah
in any event
if there's gonna be any [ __ ] talking
about
hbo max and warren brothers tonight it's
you
i will fall on that story yeah i'm i'm
done they've again smith finally stands
by as follows eviscerates bitchpio
yes
good god uh but in any event how are you
my friend uh i'm good i'm i'm very good
i'm in the the weird space of uh i'm not
currently on a gig but have a lot of
outstanding obligations that need to be
wrapped up i'm sending a kid off to to
college next week
um
already what month oh my god yeah
because we're in august we're in august
so it is it is a season of change in the
bernard household how hard is the the
you know
the the letting go
period right now i mean he's staying in
state right he's staying in state but
it's still
um
it is the weird competing the twin poles
of this is exactly what's supposed to
happen this is the course you know like
you train a kid you raise a kid and he
is supposed to leave the house
um
and so whether it be college whether it
be you know a career whether it be
whatever it is but home is not the
stasis
so on the one hand you feel great about
it because you know hey we did our job
we're sending this kid off into the
world we think we've armed him we think
we've taught him we can be we've armored
him for what's about to come and then
there's the oh my goodness
even though i don't see his face every
day now because he's an 18 year old boy
he graduated from high school who has a
job and has friends and so he's he's
already worldly and i see him three
times a week usually in the morning on
his way out
um
so i'm trying to to take it with some
semblance of sanguinidity
which i don't think is a word but [ __ ]
it i'll take it
trying to be sanguine about it i'm
trying to be sanguine about it um my
wife on the other hand is this sort of
endless
uh state of emotional catastrophe
where like every time she sees him it's
like oh hey come here buddy and then
every time she sees that growing mound
of stuff she's bought for his dorm room
so uh so yes ask for me in two weeks and
then we'll see how i'm doing this is uh
why i'm glad my kid was like i don't
want to go to college i was like number
one you're gonna save me a lot of
emotional turmoil number two you're
gonna save me a lot of money as well so
i support this decision to skip college
kids
um how awesome look at you man [ __ ]
it's the circle
[Music]
the circle of mark
well done thank you well we'll see we
still got a week and a half to go
and there's always there's always chance
for the wheels to fall off the bus
um i bought a movie theater i'm in the
process of buying one i saw that and i
was so both like this mixture of
impressed and proud
and like look at this guy [ __ ] doing
the thing in his hometown buying a movie
theater teaching the next generation how
to make movies like that's all let me
tell you
let me tell you it was
on friday like uh the
uh
uh ledger ran the piece or new jersey
dot com or whatever
uh but it was for the newark star ledger
and um
so i had to put up something because
like it kind of i'd done an interview
with amy about
uh clerks three and then we were talking
about this and she was like does anybody
know this and i was like well i mean you
know i talked about it like at my
birthday show but
like no we haven't talked about the
press she's like i'm gonna run this
first so she
uh ran the piece so i was like all right
i'll i'll put it up in my
socials let me tell you something
what a glorious 24-hour
36-hour period where there's a hundred
percent consensus
where [ __ ] people were like you know
i i may not like him or his movies but
[ __ ] this is a cool thing that he's
doing or you know [ __ ] masters of the
universe but you know what this is a
cool thing with these
um it was bliss i was like wow [ __ ]
all i ever had to do was buy a movie
theater like why did i think of this
before this is [ __ ] great
and then like we did hollywood babylon
on friday night and then by
saturday night and the article started
coming out people were like shut your
[ __ ] mouth
smith like oh i hate him
somebody call i saw a few pathetics uh i
saw
yeah i got iron pathetic um i uh i saw
uh he cries too much um you know come on
it's back to the usual ratio of like you
know people like me and then people who
don't like me and stuff
uh but for that [ __ ] one like golden
period man you had a cycle
i i felt like it was like to be tom
hanks
i was i was bringing tom hanks there man
you're untouchable nobody has anything
bad to say about you he was happy to see
at all times like [ __ ] remember you
in a volleyball in that one movie or the
feather in the other
man you work well with props you know
so i had my tom hanks friday night and
then
back to old kevin smith
sunday
the other story that i told on hollywood
babylon about strange adventures uh
is also like making the rounds now
um we'll talk about that later on yeah
um well you'll talk about it i ain't
talking about [ __ ] no more
i will say some things about some things
do you really have ideas and [ __ ]
because i sure didn't
um i mean it's i
i just had feelings i was in my feelings
as as drake says i the the ideas that i
have or the thoughts that i have which
we will get into and they're not overly
deep because we've been picking over
the corpse of these decisions you know
publicly on the internet you know on
various podcasts for about a week now um
but it's just it's all
it's all short-sighted um in a way that
you would hope
your managers of
ip and universes would not be
um but yeah we'll get into it for real
but i i i am
i am so happy that you bought a [ __ ]
movie theater um because everybody
oh my god what good time now we have a
place to do
fat man beyond back east like you know
we've we've streamed into this mod
castle small castle being a 50-seater
you know it's pretty
small we would have to do multiple shows
to satisfy the people back east who
would have liked to have been there for
like a live version of the show like we
do at
the scum and villainy cantina so now man
like we got five different theaters the
biggest one is 250 seats the smallest
one is like a hundred so even if we're
like
going to fill the 250 and people like
[ __ ] you and your show [ __ ]
myth excoriates or whatever the [ __ ] we
can just move our [ __ ] into the 99 seed
theater nice
scalability is what they call that in
the industry mark but this is the thing
uh look there's so many reasons i love
this this is the childhood theater that
i used to go to when i was a kid my
father took me there all throughout high
school friday nights at the atlantic
islands uh twin cinema at that point now
it's a five screen multiplex um being
able to uh you know own a movie theater
is a cool thing but i always felt like
you know a movie theater during the day
rather than show matinees they should
rent it to a film school and let a film
school just do their classes at it
that's all when i went to film school it
was a movie theater you know and what is
a classroom except a bunch of chairs a
big white board in front that's a
[ __ ] movie theater right there so i
was always like if i owned a movie
theater i'd rent it out to some [ __ ]
film school in the first half of the day
and then five o'clock at night it would
become a movie theater um well now i'm
about to own a movie theater and i've
got like 30 years experience making
kevin smith movies
so i was like maybe we should open the
film school like we just do ads for
dave's school all the time and stuff
like that
i'm a ambassador for the vancouver film
school the my alma mater uh but i
figured like i don't know like if we
start with a film camp program this is
what we've got planned uh next summer
like uh it would be like
june july and august or may june and
july
so each month there's a
course more like a film camp and stuff
and for the first week and a half you're
in pre-production you meet all the
instructors who go through everything
teach you how to do everything how to
order equipment [ __ ] wood equipment
equipment you would need what this
[ __ ] function is what this person
does everything next week and a half you
shoot your short and then the last week
and a half you post and then you
premiere and stuff so you got a full
month five day weeks and stuff
and and at the end of it you got this
short that you all share and since like
i would never want to be like i'm a film
school teacher because then people be
like [ __ ] you you can't even make a
movie how can you teach someone else
which i could already hear on the
internet right now um i made a fool
proof by being like oh no no i'm not
teaching you how to make a movie or a
film i'm teaching you how to make a
kevin smith movie and nobody can take
that away from me whether you like him
or not i do know how to make kevin smith
movie and so we're going to invite
people in man it's like a class of 20 or
25
um and essentially make a short in that
week and a half over that whole month
where you know the pre pre-pro short and
then you know production shoot the short
and then post-produce the short uh but
the idea would be it would be a jay and
son of bob short and every one of them
jane style and bob would meet the
monsters so you'd be shooting with me
and jay you know [ __ ] you're there
as the whole thing is [ __ ] put
together then we bring in like a famous
friend or something to play like a role
or something like that everyone you know
who's on it could be in it as well so
it's just good [ __ ] times we've been
working on it going like this will be a
fun way to get into the idea of [ __ ]
film school and stuff and you know not i
wouldn't say bulletproof but like less
assailable than i was if i was holding
forth and being like you can matriculate
and [ __ ] like that like you know
maybe one day someone will have a
credited program there but this
this would be manageable so more like uh
fantasy camp film fantasy camp so i i
know we want to do that um or i want to
do that um i know we'll be doing like
vulgar-thons festivals um i know one of
the first things we're gonna do i think
it's in october during the new york
comic con week is uh clerks open all
night so we will
start with clerks at midnight on a
friday night and then two in the morning
clerks two and then four in the morning
clerks three and then eat [ __ ] you
know bagels cream cheese and [ __ ]
convenience store food for breakfast and
[ __ ] like that so it's just a playground
to do
fun cool [ __ ] like that but
here's the [ __ ] here's the sweetest
plum mark tell me this is what i've been
oh this is what i've been saving this is
what [ __ ] like uh owning a movie
theater co-owning i'm not owning it
myself i got ashley is my partner ernie
and jeff
uh jennifer as well she's always
pointing out she's like i'm a partner
too as a god my bad yes of course i
thought that went without saying but yes
jen um
this is the sweetest plum my friend
they got these movie conventions like
show west
and stuff like that where they show
[ __ ] previews in advance and movies
in advance and [ __ ] that we always have
to read about
in news reports but never get to go
they can't stop me now dude you're an
exhibitor
thank you my friend as an exhibitor i'm
gonna be front row and be like
[ __ ] robert de niro on cape fear like
i'm there for every [ __ ] thing i'm
gonna come back to the show be like you
know what i [ __ ] saw and spoil the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of we're gonna become
the kings of the internet
for a week
yeah until well
the way i've noticed it it's like a day
cycle one day that swings back to like
you [ __ ] idiot everyone hates you
um yes that to me is is the big bonus of
owning or co-owning a theater man we're
gonna get to go to [ __ ] and see [ __ ]
early
something that i probably could manage
if i just called up some of the studios
but like
[Laughter]
now potentials now they got i will have
badges we're going to they're like comic
cons but for people that you know
exhibitors film exhibitors so i can't
wait that's gonna be a good time
oh look who's here ladies and gentlemen
it's banff man himself if mark is too
modest to put it out there i'll throw it
out there i mean it seems like a good
place to have a
east coast premiere of splinter
look at that [ __ ] there's something
thinking there's a thing that's a
he's a thing he's a thinking man's
thinking man
where are you
somebody asked me the other day and i
was like um
splinter is very close we have all of
our vfx are done
the score is done
um so we have to have a final mix down
of all the sound effects and make sure
all that plays together and our uh color
timer is at work um making it all pretty
pretty and the hope is
in the next two weeks two and a half
weeks to have
a finished
locked done final product
[ __ ] iron man yeah baby
um let me ask you this yes uh we've got
a
a full [ __ ] show to do we did um
we've got a guest m.c chris is going to
join us talk about it or that he's on um
we got a bunch of [ __ ] to review we're
going to talk about sandman
we're going to talk about prey
we're going to talk about paper girls
we're going to talk about you see bullet
train i did
i did not but we're going to talk about
bullet train uh and then we have news to
get to and stuff
um we should probably
get to it let's read an ad
and at first we were gonna start
reviewing but maybe we should get chris
and otherwise he's gonna be sitting
through [ __ ] like all those reviews
that's true so we'll read an ad we'll
bring it on chris
yeah all right so let's show proper
who's who's sponsoring tonight's show
mark who's
foolhardy enough to throw their lot in
with
fat man beyond this week we have a pair
of sponsors pair of sponsors who decided
to throw caution to the wind and help uh
fill our sails
uh the first
is native deo our good friends of native
the thoughtful formulation behind all
our products is something that we have
always loved because they understand
that it's not just what's on the outside
that counts but also what's on the
inside and that's why native is
releasing their deodorant that we know
and love in new improved plastic free
packaging kev
i love this native deodorant kids they
make deodorant they make like hair
what is it called shampoo
sometimes i smoke the words away mark
so
they make hair wash
it's like i felt like a grandmother my
grandmother just called toothpaste like
teeth while you got the teeth wash i'm
like what the [ __ ] is that um they make
shampoo
they make all stuff and it's it's uh
it's vegan as [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen
uh these people at native are so damn
brilliant uh they've teamed up with good
folks
at uh
i feel like i got old copy here this
says january
um
january
yeah i sent you it says
march but it's their summer thing
is it because this one says january 20
like native buy oh yeah yeah don't don't
read that far down okay fair enough i
was like
i just took a real [ __ ] trip back in
time when i actually looked at the copy
you better drive mark because i almost
took us right off there
you almost took us back to the future
native is also a crowd partner of the
one percent for the planet and are
committing one percent of their plastic
free deodorant sales to environmental
nonprofits and just like all of natives
other deodorants their plastic free
deodorant is aluminum and paraben free
and they have over 10 cents you know
including their classic coconut vanilla
and sensitive formulas they're
formulated without baking soda and even
unscented but why would you want to be
unscented when you can smell like
[ __ ] cupcakes why would you want to
be senseless when you could have all the
senses
indeed
senses
eviscerate the senses like kemp smith
eviscerates
don't do it
she's trying to help man don't
so if you're ready to try a plastic free
deodorant go to nativedeo.com
fatman or use the promo code fat man at
checkout and get 20 off your first order
that's nativedeo.com
batman we use promo code fat man at
checkout for 20 off your first order
he's not kidding ladies and gentlemen uh
we thank the good folks at native uh one
more time jump over to
nativedeo.com fat man give the page a
look give it a purchase
if you're feeling
stanky you want to improve that
situation or if you want to
show our sponsors that you give a [ __ ]
you must because native comes back again
and again and again okay so that's god
that says to me that y'all are buying
native thank you for that indeed i smell
good feel good native thank you to the
good folks at uh native ladies and
gentlemen for sponsoring uh the first
half of this year episode of fat man
beyond okay
got business out of the way man now we
just pleasure ladies and gentlemen
the man we're bringing on the show
uh makes my art better for my you know
i've been podcasting since 2007
and i think by maybe one two maybe three
months in on smodcast maybe four
um we got uh this guy to record a song
for us man so
this modcast was the podcast that led to
all of this you don't get to fat man
beyond unless you know i start
podcasting with moser at smodcast and
then jane silent bob get old
both of those have killer
theme songs which i'll never forget
hearing the smodcast theme song for the
first time it made me feel important
like a rock star
um you know and that and it's it set the
tone it created this little
this little anthem
in which a bubble in which we could sit
back and like do whatever it was that me
and mose used to do with our mouths to
each other which sounds way dirtier than
i meant it but you could hear the actual
episodes of jail like that
one of my favorite
artists on the planet man whose art made
has made my art better his music has
been in my movies and stuff and he's on
tour
uh right now ladies and gentlemen give
it up for the great mcp fans m.c chris
himself chris
whoa
can you hear me i can hear you sir we
have you having me we have how are you
my friend
uh i'm i'm happy to be back in l.a
although uh coming home to l.a in august
is kind of nasty it's a little hot
uh but uh i had a great tour uh just
finished uh like 50 dates in eight weeks
uh and i traveled the whole country with
my seven-year-old i'm a single dad
and that was uh
quite an experience did anybody shoot
this roll cameras on this it sounds like
a a documentary or a b a a little uh a
film a narrative
well i was definitely inspired uh i
think there was one moment where we were
watching like
plaza fury because we saw like
everything that came out this summer and
he was just like
enjoying the reclining buttons on his
movie chair and he was like laughing
because it made a squeaking sound and
i'm just like
i should be taking notes i should be
taking notes on all of this and is this
all so wonderful and fleeting that it's
all just going to escape me or
will i turn this into something someday
so i don't know he kept a travel journal
uh every day of tour so i do have a
document i can refer to um but yeah it
was like just
a crazy experience uh and it was like a
beautiful experience too like when i was
a kid we went on road trips to like
indiana and illinois and they were like
the flattest most boring places you
could imagine
and he got to see
everything that this country has to
offer uh you know everything from dc to
niagara falls to the pacific northwest
to texas and florida and
he saw it all and i can only imagine how
this is going to
stay with him i have no idea but no to
answer your question nobody documented
this but i did feel like it should be
documented did he see you in action
throughout the tour he was on stage with
me every night kevin
he was uh so i we made him yeah look a
that's adorable but b be careful that's
how yoga hoses happens man if you have
too much fun with your [ __ ] kid at
work you make a movie that everybody
hates and [ __ ] like that but you and i
know it don't [ __ ] matter because you
have some golden [ __ ] moments now for
the rest of your life living in your
head and heart your kid was on [ __ ]
state with you
say it again your kid was on stage with
you yeah i you know i just uh i just
kind of had a mistrust of america and i
just wasn't willing to like stick him in
a green room or have the openers watch
him i just only felt safe if he was
within arm's reach so
i kind of made a deal with him that he
could be dj and he could pick what songs
we did so uh he just like
figured out how to use the computer and
would uh play the songs and i think he
also developed comedic timing because he
would like
i'd say okay hit it and he would wait
and not hit it and
wait for the audience to laugh
and then i would be like come on tony
let's go and then he would look back at
me and and i would be like okay ready to
wrap and
then he'd wait for like another laugh
like he'd milk it a couple of times
until i was like okay we've gotten our
three laughs let's get out of here my
joke was always the cops are coming we
gotta go we gotta do this
and so
but yeah i know he had a great time
sometimes it was too hot in some of
these venues and he just like said he'd
like come up to me whisper sometimes
he'd be whispering in my ear while i was
rapping
and he'd be like uh can i can i use your
phone
uh you know can i play a game and sit
down in the middle of your set
yeah and i would make jokes it's like
terminator x never did any of this
nice so uh but yeah no he was i really
liked him being on stage he would dance
he would have fun and then he got into
wanting to tell jokes he'd like want to
he want to have like a little set
and it just kept on getting bigger and
bigger and i kind of had to
like put the kibosh on it and say like
people came here to see me
and uh but he was into it i don't know
what i created or what i've started but
uh you know it was just one way to like
kind of get through it i've been waiting
a tour for two years during coven and it
was just like hell just sitting around
not doing anything and and he's always
with me and so i didn't quite know how i
was gonna do it and
we just kind of made it up as we went
along
it's like a real life pursuit of
happiness the the will smith movement
yeah it was more like it was more like
paper mode where i'm like you gotta look
sadder
you know at the merge table you know you
gotta like
we're not making enough money
um but no he was great and um
you know he was so tough and i couldn't
imagine doing what he did but he like
did a great job you know he was really
tough and we'd watch kids freaking out
all summer long and like
targets and walmarts and kids just
having tantrums and he was just really
well behaved and i was really proud of
him he did a great job
so that was the tour but you you're back
here in l.a do you have final
performances here i have one last show
this saturday uh at the lodge room in
highland park
uh with jonah ray's band uh jonah ray
who does msc 3k he has this weird al
cover bands called you can't call me al
and uh so we're doing a show uh this
saturday and it's the last one uh
although every people you know i
build this tour as the last tour
uh fans ask me every night is this
really the last tour and i said time
will tell the tale if you see me again
it wasn't the last
and if you don't see me again this is it
i'm sorry goodbye
uh but i have no way of knowing but i do
have like i have to be in dragon con in
two weeks and i have
private parties that are booking me now
and uh
so i think people are kind of coming out
of their
their holes like snow white woodland
creatures you know after the storm uh
you know where they're just kind of like
is it okay to party
and and of course that's making them
party too hard
uh but uh yeah so things are kind of
coming back to normal now and uh but i
don't know what's gonna happen um i know
that's very difficult to tour with a
seven-year-old and uh i don't know if i
can do it again
where can they get tickets for
saturday's show before we keep before we
go on they can go to mccrist.com
and uh there's ticket links right there
at the top
um now you go way back to adult swim is
that where you started rapping where the
nerd core began
uh i started rapping in nyu around 1995
[Music]
and um
it was just like a way for me to deal
with like feeling meaningless in
manhattan because manhattan was like i
came from chicago which was a kind of a
doable city but manhattan was just like
endless chicago so i had no confidence i
had no um where with all like at parties
like how to talk to people i so i just
kind of
came up with this alter ego and i lived
with these punk rockers who made music
all the time and taught me pretty much
everything that i utilized as a touring
artist
and they started to record me they
started to bring me up on stage if they
broke a guitar string
and that's where it started and then
when i got involved at upright citizens
brigade and then got to uh interview for
adult swim
and played my music at adult swim and
like at the interview and they put the
song i played at the interview that's
vet they put that in
the show and it connected with
a huge audience that had never had
anything like that before in their lives
and then once i discovered my audience i
was able to
cultivate it keep making albums then i
just made more money doing that than i
did at cartoon network
um which is a wb company by the way a
discovery plus company
i found a side hustle as many
employees there probably have figured
out to do over the years and uh that
side hustle just became more lucrative
and um and yeah and so
it was it was because adult swim played
the song that it connected with so many
people and kind of
uh created a
you know a generational shift or a
movement or whatever you want to call it
but it definitely kind of everyone's
ears perked up and they're like this is
something that i want
and i was just kind of right place right
time
were you a genre of one at that point
was anybody else
i didn't know of anybody else although
i'd when people say you invented this or
you came up with this i'm like sugar
hill
sugar hill was rapping about superman
and like their first single
so and wu-tang
dropped so many marvel references
and um rappers are usually nerds
trying to act tough you know they are
writers and they are intelligent and um
they have a great sense of word play and
great sense of the language and
so i feel like nerdy references were
kind of always a part of hip-hop i think
i was the first one to write a rap song
about boba fett
and once i did that and everyone was
just like me likey i was kind of like
okay i'm gonna like mass produce that
and just write about
the boba fetts of the world and the boba
fetts of different universes and
whatever that may be
do you memorize everything
um
well i have
a lot memorized i feel like i have a
couple shakespearean plays up in my head
um so there were there have been tours
where i've just done requests and
uh but i recently became sober or like
within like you know eight months ago i
became sober and stopped stop smoking
and then i just realized that like it's
all in there
it's it's all there
which is amazing to me once i started
rehearsing and for tour and i was like i
remember all these songs that i haven't
done in 15 years and because i brought
out a lot of old songs for this tour
and i was just amazed to find out that
that it's all up there which is crazy
[ __ ] night banff man i don't know we
cut you off what's up i'm just going to
say
some of the
top
songs played at scum and villainy are
fetch vet ig 88's 57 chevy like people
love that stuff at scum and villainy
thank you
uh yeah no i mean i
every night of this past tour i had a
little monologue that i would do before
i did fence vet where i told the tale of
how i wrote the song in jersey city
um after being fired
and how it led to all this crazy stuff
like being on adult swim and um
connecting with the audience and touring
the country and then i said and then
some crazy [ __ ] started to happen where
i like slept at skywalker ranch and i
met
george lucas and saw howard the duck's
guitar and and got to screen revenge of
the sith in their private theater and
became friends with boba fett and the
prequels and jeremy bullock would walk
on stage at celebration and they played
the song and then i would say and then
kevin smith put it in a movie called
zakamiri make porno
and everybody would cheer
and then i'd say and then and then kevin
smith proceeded to hire me for a decade
when not many people would
and um
and now he's my friend and i can text
him all the time and he always says the
same thing no matter what i say he's
always like who are you leave me alone
i have a lot of mc's in my phone man
there's true but you've got a big laugh
every night
you've always been awesome thank you for
that man that's awesome it does occur to
me that there's a lot of similarities
between both of you guys right and that
you know you found out what you wanted
to do young you had some success and
that success was was
driven in great part by finding your
audience and then giving them what they
wanted
you know and then finding ways by doing
so
to achieve some level of freedom
not so much as like fame or riches or
whatever it is but the ability to then
make your art on your terms
i think it's beautiful
yeah for sure uh i i
the point i really tried to impress upon
the audience by the end of the show was
that
i made this song when i was feeling
penniless and hopeless and i was not in
a relationship i had no money i had no
job i didn't know what's going to happen
to me but i was true to myself in that
moment
and i was able to connect with millions
of people all over the planet and it's
given me a career that's lasted 25 years
and um it's really important uh if
you're going through some kind of
struggle
to remember what you what you enjoy and
who you are and be true to that and
sometimes the rewards are just like you
can't predict what's going to happen but
because you are true to yourself
uh amazing things can happen like just
being here tonight talking to you guys
being friends with kevin that all
happened because i uh made this song you
know
um and made many uh songs
after that
yes
before we brought you on man i was
talking about how like i
i i always felt so much more important
than i was whenever the theme for
spodcast began
like it was just it was anthemic and
nobody had ever you know people written
scores for movies that i'd done
but nobody ever had ever written an
anthem and like stuck my name in it and
oh it's still to this day it's one of my
that's i want them to play that at my
funeral over and over again
where people are like creeped and
irritated by it but it's just you know
it's such an
ear worm like was the closest you've
ever gotten to being a professional
wrestler right when like john cena rolls
out and they play the john cena song
like you got your [ __ ] entry song
that's true and i've gone out on stage
to it like it's preceded me whether i'm
in this room recording a show or like
when i've i've gone out on stage in
front of like 6 000 people with that
song pumping the [ __ ] crowd up and
stuff
um and on on uh reboot the movie we just
finished i used uh
another uh track um
drinking drink [ __ ] i always
just drinking blood smoking 40 smoking
40s drinking blood um
yeah man
your art has always
made my quote unquote art uh better what
is the
what do you think is the of the nerd
things that you have wrapped about what
do you feel
is the most
like [ __ ] razor sharp
pop culture surgeon
pop culture reference that you've
dropped in any song thus far fetch vets
wonderful but you know fed is accessible
to
to a lot of folks what reference have
you made that's like [ __ ] three
people got it and they were like that
was gold
uh
well
i don't know about that i i think you
know i made us i've i kept on making
star wars songs
and um i made a side on ethanol song
which i love
um and i don't know if anyone else loves
it
uh i think you know i'm still kind of
been the same person over the past 20
years
and i've always just been kind of doing
following my heart and always kind of
like looking for those boba fetts
meaning like looking for those tertiary
characters that are kind of
maybe not really heralded and not really
noticed or not celebrated in any way and
then i kind of dive in and
try to um
celebrate them and it's funny that i did
this i don't sign on the thano song
and then the guy who wrote the sidon
athano book
tweeted at me and he was like
i can't believe
that i'm in an empty chris song i mean i
did the moon i did a moon night song uh
for april fools because i always
released a song on april fools and the
executive producer of the moon night
show was like i can't believe
that uh m.c chris made a moon night song
and released it on the day that our show
comes out
and all that stuff is just like
crazy because i i feel like i have no
idea who's out there and who's listening
and sometimes it feels like no one's out
there it's kind of felt like that the
whole time because when you're an artist
you're kind of alone and you're just
writing in a room by yourself you don't
know if you're connecting with anybody
you're just kind of making something
it's like a message in a bottle and you
just kind of throw it out
and you don't know if it's going to
reach anybody and then it reaches like
important people executive producers and
people that write books and and people
that are actually dealing with these ips
and uh it's crazy it's it's like an
unreal
existence
um it's a dream existence man
particularly one that i'm sure a lot of
folks in our audience particularly be
like what
like this is a job you could literally
rap about all these things and and make
a healthy living as you pointed out
you've been doing it for over two
[ __ ] decades man yeah
oh
[ __ ] good for you um where when one
more time with the sat with the show
here in los angeles this is the last
show of the tour
yeah it's the the promoter wants me to
like really uh
say that it's the last show ever he
really wants everyone to think it's the
last show ever but um i'm i'm a
performer and i can't stop performing
and i just think um you know i say to my
son
when you know he's gonna get older and
he's gonna want me to go back out on the
road and i'm gonna be 55 and i'd be like
no
but the show is it's uh lodge room in
highland park in los angeles uh this
saturday uh with jonah ray's fan you
can't call me out and you can get
tickets at mcchris.com
um i sense uh
next time you go out on the road it's
m.c and sun
yeah he has a name he he wanted everyone
to like call him mcskullcracker uh all
summer
so he's you know and he he raps in
gibberish right now and i'm just like i
know these are gonna become words i
don't really wish it upon him i don't
like you said with yoga hosers i don't
really want this life for him but i also
want to encourage whatever he wants to
do whatever he loves you know
but um yeah it's been a it's been a
crazy summer
you're a [ __ ] terrific dad sir well
done man you you're doing it correctly
thank you absolutely i'm definitely
my dad would take me to work uh and i
got to like draw on the white board at
the chicago mercantile exchange and that
would be like
one day
i can only imagine how annoyed he would
have been if had i been there every day
for two months
but uh we got through it
then you all said you win you take your
kid to work day though you really yeah
no i mean i definitely took him to work
i showed him the whole country my my
office is the whole country so it was
kind of i love america and i loved
showing it to him it was pretty great
experience
that is the sweetest thing you're going
to hear all week kids
m.c chris an emcee skullcracker
father and son on the road again finding
america the real america kids
uh the show is saturday night uh ladies
and gentlemen uh tickets at
mcchris.com yes sir
uh you continue to spot inspire and be
amazing uh but man you're giving jason
muse a run for his money his best dad
well done kid
yeah he's a mess
i'm the best
just kidding jay
you don't watch this show
so you can say whatever you want uh give
it up for mc chris everybody thank you
for having me guys
good to meet you man good luck on
saturday man big legs thank you take
care
i would totally go to that show but i'm
going to be in boston at fan expo
going to pass
this weekend kids so i won't be at the
m.c chris show sadly otherwise i'd be
[ __ ] there
god he can rap so fast too he spits
lyrics man
every time i i hear from or talk to a
rapper um who's always like yeah no
everything's still in there it takes me
like figuring out the mnemonic device to
trigger it all and then like the
floodgates will open
and i can remember interviewing lin
miranda before he was going to puerto
rico to do hamilton again i was like is
it hard like getting it all back he's
like no
no it's
i've still got
400 pages worth of lyrics in my head i
just need to get back to it imagine
somebody puts a gun to your head
and says
recite
the script for splinter
how soon do they [ __ ] pull that
trigger
um i don't know but before we rolled the
camera today you and i were doing a
rendition of lotty dottie it's true
you're like and
pretty note perfect a song that neither
of us i will wager have heard in 20
years that's true music it's music man
like
it's the
lyrical nature of it the rhyme the
anticipation of the rhyme and the meter
i guess that's
easier to
recall than like a whole ass script or
something like that yeah and i think
that a lot of it has to do with you know
music is a conduit to emotion which is a
conduit to memory and so you can then
remember the place and the time you were
when you first heard that song
i remember being whatever 12 or 13 years
old in my bedroom trying to catch
the songs that aired on the on the radio
on like wbls
on some like friday night rap show
trying to make sure that i got it just
after the dj queued it up it's like
lottie dottie relaxed a party
and then i guarantee you
what what the only thing that would make
that sweeter now is like as kids we
would try to edit out the dj
now i would [ __ ] kill
to hear like dj red alert from circa
1982
to 1986 or something like that yeah
you would have tried to cut out of your
mix tape because you're like i just want
the song but now like i find myself
cause i'm an old ass [ __ ] man a
pathetic one as the internet has told me
um i will uh periodically like go
[ __ ] deep diving for like casey's
coast to coast just
listen to a whole [ __ ] sunday morning
of of him doing the top 40
countdown like
just because it is a conduit to [ __ ]
memory like as i sit there listening not
just to the songs but also of course him
and his long distance dedication
i'm i'm transported right back to 21
jackson street you know as a kid in
highlands and like you built your
weekend around
that [ __ ] show like oh we're going to
hear the top 40 man we're going to
listen to it from [ __ ] like 10 in the
morning to 10 in the morning until like
two or whatever [ __ ] it was on
yeah like i love i love
like uncovering old vh vhs tapes of like
here's where i taped you know the third
season of star trek the next generation
live on the air
and like
yeah i could fast forward past the
commercials but that's actually what i
want like i just want the experience of
still being back in 1991 or whatever the
[ __ ] it was that's the sweetest plum
sometimes i sit here and when my work's
done i [ __ ] light a joint i go to
youtube and i'll watch commercials 1984.
[Laughter]
people will string together two hours of
[ __ ] commercials and like i could
sing
every one of the jingles even [ __ ] 30
40 years later like
songs are the song is powerful man like
if we had any brains we would have went
into music [ __ ]
movies when you go to movies you get
yelled at by people all the time like
that's my fault
musicians
they singers they never get yelled at
everybody loves a singer
throwing panties up on the stage oh my
good lord man like
taylor swift everyone loves her
nobody don't like
i guess at the end of the day there are
haters everywhere
they grow on trees
um let's uh
let's dive in shall we indeed there's
talk about some [ __ ] do we talk about
some [ __ ] we saw did we save the big
fish for last
yeah i mean we can we can we can uh we
can skip along the surface of the water
with uh with some other things
let's not just let's not [ __ ]
blow him first let's
let's let's let's edge him a little bit
mark talk about all the other
[ __ ] before we [ __ ] dive into the
sandman of it all
we uh we we watched some [ __ ] me and
mark both watched the sandman me and
mark both watched
pray
although he probably saw more of it than
i did and uh i watched paper girls
and mark saw a bullet train yes so
we have a [ __ ] ton
of content
to cover tonight kids more [ __ ]
content
than you could shake a chogren mall rat
at kids
look at that jay and sabah vinyl mall
rats available at
jsonbob.com
side commercial right there a little
side hustle mark
like you gotta have you're doing no side
hustle gotta wear a lot of hats um
let's start with bullet train because
i'm very curious about this motion
picture
um bullet train if you're not familiar
with said bullet train is a brad pitt um
starring enterprise in which he plays a
uh
operative it's very unclear what you
know his his usual job is
but he seems to be like a retrieval
expert he's hired to get on this train
pick up this briefcase and then get off
the train with the briefcase and into
that simple mission a bunch of [ __ ] sort
of falls there's assassins on the train
there's a bethenny's on the train
there's mob children on the train
there's you know heartbroken fathers on
the train
but ultimately it's it's sort of a
good-natured comedy from the guy who
directed deadpool 2
and john wick two i believe
no no he was a co-director of john mc1
and he did either he was uh brad pitt's
old stunt double or something like that
yeah david leach is his family with chad
stahlske who was kiana reeves stunt
double for a long time um they made john
wick and then they both kind of went
their separate ways to become this sort
of new crop of action directors who have
you know in great fashion in the way
that john wake has sort of redefined
how sort of modern action looks these
two guys are the directors who seem to
be in shepherding
similar to maybe not similar these guys
are way more advanced but not all that
dissimilar from i got to be careful i
got to choose my words carefully mark or
else i read [ __ ] like
smith lashes out
um do you remember in the 70s
there was a well-known uh stunt
man
coordinator slash stunt coordinator by
the name of hal needham
i do
hal needham was the burt reynolds guy
stunt double
who aggregated to directing some of the
most beloved [ __ ] movies
of our childhood aka smokey and the
bandit
[ __ ] the cannonball run movies
hooper
uh the movie about the stuntman uh
so
there you know there is a long history
of stuntmen and i'm sure stunt women
stunt people let's say
uh who
you know start as stunts and then slowly
aggregate
to directing and people like how's that
happen because when you're a stunt
coordinator
you kind of take over
directing at that point because you know
everything in order to get the shot
accomplished you've gone through the
shots of the director the director
signed off on him and stuff
but you are
composing the kids that i would do
a flash and supergirl with their
simon and the stunt team
those those cats were practically the
directors you know anytime there's an
action sequence they they were in charge
they pre-shot everything showed you what
it looks like and stuff and they're like
[ __ ] that's real tight yeah on the
splinter like we had we brought in the
stone coordinator a guy named himself
and when it was time for a stunt i was
like himself you're set
like these are your people you brought
on your their safety is in your hands
for these four shots like it's your set
man do you tell us when to go and when
to stop
what is the i'm going to show my
ignorance because uh
my
smoked it away but uh the director of
snakes on a plane
uh david
um somebody look it up real quick
panthman if you
haven't you could chime in
um
was such a lovely dude he did he
directed uh
um
what was that picture called uh the
final destination
banff man david ellis
thank you david
great the great david ellis he directed
a lot of the final destination movies
and he directed snakes on a plane
david was a stunt guy
like slowly moved up he became a stunt
coordinator and then stunt coordinators
tend up tend to do what they call second
unit you know the main director is off
directing first unit or whatever they're
like oh we'll be over here shooting this
stunt and then the director sees the
footage and approves and so forth and so
on so they get practice directing off by
themselves running a second unit because
they know all the angles the shots how
to shoot it so somebody don't get hurt
and [ __ ]
so david became a director he went from
being a stunt guy to a drug he was such
a [ __ ] lovely dude he worked with us
on cop-out he was warner brothers go-to
um second unit director like you got
would be like you know i i didn't do a
lot of action prior to that and so we
had a car chase and and i was like well
i you know i'll give you something but
you probably won't like it and they're
like we'll bring on david ellis and so
david had written me before getting
there and he was like hey thanks for
having me on your movie this this is a
man who made snakes on a plane he was
being polite about being invited to this
[ __ ] movie and [ __ ] and so um he was
like uh you know i can't wait to work
with you is it true you're a stoner
and i was like yeah and a week later he
had sent me a package and [ __ ] in it
was a ton of weed
so he told me this lovely story he's so
he was he's passed unfortunately we lost
david ellis um but he told me a lovely a
really funny story about
being in a city you know where that he
wasn't from he was in a different state
and you know he's a stunt man for a
living
but uh he got lost uh and followed
uh
and
tailgated into a uh cul-de-sac
um
by some rough customers and stuff
and so boom they
backed him into it he had no way out
around them and he was facing the other
way
so
you know he was like
i figure i'm [ __ ]
so i just went for the job and he
[ __ ] slammed on
it did [ __ ] 360 donuts in front of
these guys as they got out of their
[ __ ] car
and [ __ ] it and spun to [ __ ] face
them
vroom then ran the engine and [ __ ]
it
up i was like they chase you and goes
[ __ ] no they were not expecting that
like he was like i was in a [ __ ] box
nova or a dodge or something like that
he's like but i could drive a [ __ ]
car man like i could really
but he's like their faces just watching
their faces because they thought like
they're getting out they're approaching
his car look at her pick this guy off
and the fact that the dude instantly put
on a stunt show in front of him to
escape
he was like i'll never forget their
expressions like holy [ __ ] welcome to
the water world stunt spectacular with
universal studios could you imagine man
it's so delightful um so yeah man that's
the uh that dude
i could anyway back to your review yes
david lynch who directed this movie and
it's
it's uh it's a ton of fun
i can't say that it's great because it
isn't but it's also not trying to be um
it's relevant right yeah i mean it's
brad pitt just having a good [ __ ]
time the movie seems to know exactly
what it is which is this very like
highly stylized kind of kill bill meets
you know tarantino well no that is
gentino it's killer bill meets like john
wick
in an incredibly jokey kind of way and
then meets a little bit of like big
trouble in little china
in that you know
brad pitt is playing this
larger-than-life guy who's like
struggling with his own sense of sin and
how he wants to get out of his business
but he can pull back in and
and there's it's the lovely cast of
rando odd wonderful people there's a
bunch of cameos that i won't spoil
um but that are that are just fun
and the action's really strong um
brian tyree henry and aaron taylor
johnson play a pair of
other sort of hit men who are on a gig
and they're hilarious um i've never i've
never
i've never seen like the aaron tell a
johnson movie that i loved i mean i
liked hitman but you know that was less
about him and more about the movie
itself
but he's a write um and he's having so
much fun and i will watch brian terry
henry do almost anything including being
godzilla v kong
which is one of the worst movies i've
ever seen that made like
four hundred million dollars at the box
numbers but
anyway um
if you're in the mood for a good time at
the movies and if you've seen everything
else you wanted to see
um
and uh and since prey is not its
competition in the movie theaters um
you don't see bullet train it's a
it's it's a hair too long as most movies
are except we can't tell about prey pray
is a very taut very like wonderful like
98 minutes
um
but uh bullet train it gets it gets like
a solid like
b
b plus if you're in the right lead
there it is kids [ __ ]
bullet train worth [ __ ] saying worth
[ __ ] seeing um you didn't see paper
girls i've not seen paper girls yet this
this was the weekend of
deep diving into
um
an endless
font of uh of content
endless being the operative word me as
well uh we started with paper girls and
[ __ ] is it delightful it's only eight
episodes each episode's like
half an hour maybe 33 minutes or some
such [ __ ]
charming as [ __ ] i i knew the comic but
i didn't read the comic i was familiar
with the existence of the comic and i
remember my kid at one point had said
like
did you ever read paper girls when she
was working at uh the dc show
it's really good and i was like i'll get
around to it and i never got around to
it and in some ways i'm glad that i
didn't because the the [ __ ] show is
incredibly surprising
at one point
like i don't want to spoil it but i
think i got it in order to [ __ ] like
get some people to
maybe give it a shot some people might
be like ah
it's time traveling [ __ ] show
these four girls on bikes and i didn't
watch stranger things but i took my kid
harley made me watch the pilot for the
first episode rather of uh
of paper girls and she was a big
stranger things kid so i was like four
girls on bikes in that show like four
boys on bikes and [ __ ] she goes that's
about the only similarity
between them
that's okay
um it starts off with four paper girls
who wind up kind of getting together in
1988
and then they [ __ ] fall essentially
through a time hole and meet
their older [ __ ] selves in two
different decades there's a giant
[ __ ] robot at one point
cool that gets piloted and [ __ ] like
they're fighting a war in the future it
it is so [ __ ] up and delightful like i
had no idea that's what it was um it's
imaginative i think it's brian
and cliff chang and cliff chang
[ __ ] man like
what a delightful ride it was all the
actresses the kids who played the the
leads were wonderful
um and then the their adult counterparts
i think
like allie wong was one of them i
believe
um great job across the board uh [ __ ]
original story that i'd never seen
before
um
you know sweet cool notions of like
oh my god like you know most sci-fi and
time travel is like you can't meet your
[ __ ] cell phone you'll disappear
this wasn't that so you had these long
lovely scenes between the young versions
of the characters
and the old versions of the characters
like
counseling back and forth so
sweetly well done and
faster than [ __ ] light like they're
they're very brief episodes but
incredibly
imaginative one of those things where i
was like jesus man like i gotta get out
of this game like
people are far more inventive than i i'm
you know [ __ ] they're making [ __ ]
like paper girls i'm making [ __ ] like
clerks the third you know what i'm
saying like
something wrong here um because
that's the future you know [ __ ]
intricate layered storytelling about
[ __ ] characters you've never seen
before you know
clerks is like hey it's two dudes who
are convenience stores you know
you've seen that before because i've
showed it to you before this i went on a
journey incredible journey and stuff
look there's room for all kinds of
entertainment
i was just delighted that i spent my
time with this eight episodes
half hour piece what is that
[ __ ] four hours max something like
that if that's how time works was
absolutely worth the [ __ ] time i was
delighted the whole time i split it
between two nights
uh or a night and then like i got up the
next morning i woke my wife up i was
like get up we gotta go back to watching
that show uh because it was just so like
what like i couldn't believe that the i
think it was a fourth episode all of a
sudden they introduced a giant [ __ ]
robot and i'm like like a you know like
a [ __ ] voltron like
get in the giant robot and [ __ ] walk
around like
that's badass yeah [ __ ] like who saw
that [ __ ] coming yeah i mean i i very
much want to watch the show because i've
been a brian k vaughn fan since forever
since while last man um and and has
developed and blossomed and remains like
this magnificent storyteller um and he's
he both he and clif chang were just
lovely lovely human beings like cliff
was one of the first artists that i ever
spoke to about adora in the distance
um because at this point now it's like
15 years ago
we went out to dinner in manhattan and i
was just sort of loose pitching him what
the idea was because i very much wanted
him to draw it every time
and he was like listen i think this is
beautiful and i love it but i'm
committed to
x y z i think he was like on a wonder
woman run with maybe greg rucker or
somebody and then
you know i think paper girls were still
a ways off but like he was just over
committed because he's as insanely
talented as he is but i ran into them
both at this uh this comic-con party
that amazon threw
um that was organized by my friend kayla
and it was uh it was just so nice to see
those guys like it was one of my
favorite parts of comic con which is to
see people that i've known for a decade
or so
get their moment in the sun with uh
adaptation of their work that they can
be proud of because all too often that
is not the way it goes down
um but
you muted brian had uh
uh
why the last man which like
they they had for a minute and then all
of a sudden hulu was like we're done and
very unceremonious it seems like this is
getting a lot of attention and positive
attention like i don't know who gauges
whether these things are successful or
not but it feels like it's a hit for
amazon because i've seen lots of people
talking about once i started watching it
i had to go [ __ ] you know like diving
going like is everybody else watching
and i was not alone it's not like hey
let me tell you about this best kept
secret so amazon like two things this
year that [ __ ] really impressed me
this and reacher and i would like to see
them cross over oh that would be nice
could you imagine paper girls versus
reacher
first they fight but then they're
friends you know that's how it goes yeah
i did i did watch the show um i finished
watching my show i started it in the
sort of pandemic lockdown and dropped
off for no good reason but i thought of
you while i was watching it um
reservation dogs have you seen
i keep wanting to watch it it's isn't
taika waititi a producer or something
taika white tv is a producer sterling
sterling harjo is the creator and show
winner um but it's
it's just lovely like it it presents as
a sort of like slice of life kind of
comedy it's half hour long
about these four kids who grew up on a
reservation
um
but and it is very funny and these kids
who are all have never i think been in
anything before are all fantastic they
all feel very very real and so there's
this this sort of
laziness to the to the storytelling
which very much
mates with the the perspective of the
show
and then it gets like really serious and
like really moving and really kind of
heartwarming especially later in that
first season run and as you come into
the second season which just dropped on
hulu um this past week um it's beautiful
and it's just it's doing things that
um i've never seen a show quite like it
do
um with people who've never been in
anything before do
um i think you'd really appreciate it i
think especially in the in the clerk's
vibe
of like we're making a show and we're
we're putting together and we have our
stories and it's going to be funny and
it's going to be real and it's going to
be heartfelt and it's it's going to move
people in ways they didn't expect to be
moved um you know i think it's i think
it's wonderful and it did mate very
nicely with prey
um which watching them sort of back to
back in this like indigenous
entertainment zone of like huh
like you know what [ __ ] yeah let's tell
more of these stories and let these
people tell their own stories
and stories like one stories that are
like this is a reflection of life and
this is clearly a story yes very much
but still
what uh we'll talk about that in one sec
we should point out because some people
ask hey where can i watch paper girls
that's on amazon kids amazon prime yeah
um if you want to watch uh
uh bullet train you gotta go to the
movies if you wanted to watch reza
reservation dogs that's on fx on hulu
fxo
uh
if you wanna watch pray
and [ __ ] you should want to watch pray
that's on hulu for some reason why did
why did that happen look look i'm going
to choose my tone carefully mark so that
people aren't like smith
tears hulu a new [ __ ] so i'm just
gonna ask inquisitively here can i can i
write the clickbait headlines go ahead
it's inquired
why did this not go to theaters this
movie was like one of the best
moviegoing experiences i've had in quite
some time i would have imagined like
this could have totally killed at a
movie theater
was there a
was it always intended to be a hulu only
release um i i'm not criticizing i don't
want this to read as smith says hulu
droppable i'm just curious because this
movie the production value
and the storytelling was completely
cinematic
it was i mean i think that some of that
decision which was made pre-pandemic i
think to go straight to streaming
um
does factor in the fact that
the predator as a franchise has not been
like some box office behemoth
um the last couple of predator movies
did not be particularly well um the
original itself was a fairly low budget
affair it was like a 15 or 20 million
dollar budget and it did well it made
you know 60 or 70. um
the next the sequel the danny glover
movie you know did also fine alien
versus predator probably did about as
well as these predator movies have done
that was like the biggest of them and so
sort of hedging their bets as to is this
actually going to
draw
a wide audience given that it really
never has before like let's put it on
stream
um
which does seem to have been ultimately
for hulu a great idea because it's like
the most watched thing i think that's
ever been on their network ever is that
right is that right
the news came out today that like
disney said the film scored in the
number one premiere on hulu today
including all film and tv series debuts
well that's [ __ ] fantastic i'm glad
they got rewarded dan trachtenberg is he
the director dan trachtenberg is the
director who did 10 cloverfield lane um
he did he did more than that dan
tragdenberg is the guy that introduced
me to podcasting yeah
show years ago him and his friend
called
not squad because that's the geek show
maybe i don't know but essentially they
were the first ones i ever sat down with
they came to our office like back in
2005
2006 it was 2006
because clerks 2 was done
and uh they brought their equipment and
they were like we want to interview for
a podcast and you know they [ __ ] did
it in front of me and i was like
this is it like this counts this is a
show
and they were like yeah we just sit
around and we just talk about [ __ ] um
they
they made me go like i think i would
like to do one of this on a regular
basis i tried to become their third man
but
they already had a good thing going and
stuff and then they eventually split up
and then i saw him years later
and he was like uh oh [ __ ] man i'm a
director now and i was like that's right
because i saw you directed like one of
the clover fields and he also directed
the pilot for the boys
but amazon this guy's [ __ ] talented
man
like crazy challenging because that prey
movie
is dynamite the girl is amazing the dog
is amazing
who now i just want to see a series of
predator through history movies like
i i understand this one's special for
many more reasons than just the like hey
we went to a different time period but
i think this pumped new life into the
i think very much so i mean very much so
because it had gotten mired in its own
like i don't even say continuity but in
its it kind of crawled up its own ass a
little bit
in ways that that ultimately didn't
benefit it and the simplicity of this
movie is what i was struck by
you know and yes like there are but so
many characters that you can just drop
into alternate timelines but i wouldn't
mind seeing like hey what if the alien
came to you know 1523
japan
or whatever had to fight samurais yeah
man give me the aliens versus hammer
what if what if he was jack the ripper
like he was in
white chapel or whatever the [ __ ]
wasn't a guy it was the [ __ ] predator
yeah but i mean it's a thing that had
been established i think mostly in
predator 2
the idea that this is not the first time
that this this species has visited earth
and that it's something of a training
ground for their own sort of young
hunters
um
but it's like yeah like amber
mid-thunder who plays the lead um
the league woman naru i think her name
is is wonderful like she's so good the
dog is great the entire cast
is unbelievable but yes the direction
and it's the writing by patrick ason
who i worked with on on treadstone um
and it's
like it does all the things you wanted
to do and it does them incredibly well
um it reminded me a lot of apocalypto
um not in that it was directed by a
monster but in that it's a
indigenous movie dan trachtenberg and
mel gibson are interchangeable
smith tears trachtenberg
smith awaits
horror monster mel gibson with very nice
dan trachtenberg
um
the the
amber mid thunder i think that's her
name
[ __ ] phenomenal now i
i i hesitate to ask but like are they
are they leaving are they leaving this
alone like is people are people like
coming after it is it
i mean there is a little bit of as you
imagine there would be
come on because the movie's so good like
the movie's so good the movie's so well
done and it it does you know
especially for me coming on the heels of
watching
reservation dogs
you know which is like this is a native
production this is an indigenous
production the writing staff is all made
of indigenous people and the entire cast
and all of that makes sense and yes prey
was
directed by a white dude and written by
what
um
but i think that there there
there is the intention and the desire
and i'm not sure if how soon into the
process they came upon the idea of
setting in the 1700s in the comanche um
but if you're going to do it and you're
going to do the job of a writer which is
to actually tell stories of characters
who don't exist and if you're even if
you're trying to tell a historical story
is to do the work and to make it feel
right and to make it you know sort of
play nicely with all of the cultural
specificity that you wanted to and you
get there by research you get there with
consultants you get there with they did
have a comanche producer who helped make
this movie you know and i and i don't
think you can look at that movie and say
this was
disrespectful
of of the comanche and that was in some
way betrayal of what that meant would
have been nice sure
but i don't think a person should be
penalized because they want to tell a
great story
um and then tell that great story well
so yeah i think it's you know it's
it is getting a little bit of of of heat
from that quarter but i think the fact
that it's very very good
has somewhat
insulated it from that from that uh
andrew camacho and chad has written also
worth noting that there is a comanche
dub for prey
in case anyone wants an even more
authentic experience yes i guess on hulu
they've included what he calls a
comanche dub
yeah which i think is fantastic um
but i i just i i was so taken by this
movie
because hey it does things very much
like the original did
but it reminded me a bit of um fury road
in that it's a very simple story
like this is a movie about like i'm i'm
a young you know comanche brave i want
to go on my hunt i want to get my my
[ __ ] you know my stripes and i want
to be a full member a hunter in this
tribe and how do i do that by taking
down the biggest baddest thing that's in
the wild which for her she thinks it's a
mountain lion but it turns out to be a
predator and so it's just this very
simple linear emotional story of i just
want to be big i want to be an adult i
want to be an adult in the eyes of my
elders and my people and how do i get to
do that by actually defending my elders
and my people from something that nobody
else could
and it's just so simple that way but
it's just done so effectively
um
yeah that's i loved it today
um
i loved it as well ooh banff man is here
before batman says a word two nickels
says i look super baked and chat i'm not
i wish i could get super big man like
that's days are gone my friend sadly uh
over to you banff man what kind of we
had
a couple
uh pray comments in chat i wanted to
point out bobby jackson and somebody
else said fox had a deal
pre disney to release on hbo after
theatrical
once disney bought fox they had to skip
theatrical and put it on hulu or else
hbo would have taken the streaming
there it is now we have an explanation
and then
oh god
i was just going to say like that
they would have had streaming debut
rights but at some point those rights
would likely have reverted back to
disney so it would have been in the hulu
ecosystem eventually and so then the
question becomes
is the money you might have made
theatrically worth
that first
streaming hit going to somebody else um
and that's the question that nobody has
an answer for him which is how well
might it have done
i think what we're seeing more recently
you know we've all been enjoying
uh the rise of streamers and the
streaming wars and stuff and uh watching
them all spend money for our attention
like we're going to make this we're
going to make this i mean look
we got a
spoilers brilliant [ __ ] version of
the sandman after nearly 30 [ __ ]
years because
of streamers like going like we're gonna
spend to kind of get your attention
uh but the economics of how
you know what something costs versus
what they can get back for it
we're starting to
see more of that at play i think that's
had everything to do with all the news
from
from uh
i'm gonna say this incredibly calmly so
nobody says that i
shredded them or something
warner brother discovery it feels like
the we're hearing so much backstage like
well we're going to try to save this
much money this costs 90. we're going to
write it down
because
it's
now we're now in a phase of the business
where
like the dust is settling and they have
to figure out
how a thing makes
money
like you know if you're gonna put it in
theaters they can figure out pretty
quickly whether or not it's a thing that
makes money
with streaming they you know netflix has
their own equation where
the amount of time a thing is watched
aggregates into
value it's not even a dollar for
minute basis it's it's a very it's a
as we know an algorithm um
you know the
having an expensive
movie that you're not going to take
theatrical so there's no revenue stream
there but just the revenue stream from
wherever you're going to show it in in
the case of let's say
i don't even want to use examples
because i [ __ ] get yelled at and get
in trouble
so let's say they have
you know
movie a
um that
is only ever going to play on streamer
service
a and there's no way for them to
monetize that movie beyond that one
that one venue
and
they already know that it's not like
they're going to get a bunch of new
memberships signing up just for
that particular movie so it seems like
you know a lot of the businesses are
taking a pause that they had not taken
up until this moment in time
where it was just like make make content
is king like just keep making stuff and
the budgets went up and up
suddenly
it looks like everybody's going well
hold on like
when is it
even out when does the money we spend
equal
like asses and seats or whatever
everyone's figuring out a new business
map is what it smells like i don't
[ __ ] know i have no access to the
corridors or halls of power but from the
outside since we keep hearing so much
about
the business and stuff
and about like things that are getting
things that have never been done before
you know like some of those
announcements that came out from from uh
the warner brothers discovery thing
i think it has everything to do with all
the streamers
suddenly realizing like
uh okay
we're in our positions but now we have
to figure out like
what
is this worth it anymore like is is a
thing too big
when is a thing too big um you know
obviously in the case of say
the gray man which we all knew about was
a very expensive movie
instantly they green lit a sequel so
according to their algorithm like
they did the business that they needed
to do with that particular thing i don't
know it's just been interesting sitting
on the outside which is completely what
i am an outsider
but knowing a lot about the business
just being like why would one do that
and then you realize
so many things about that new version of
the business
that i don't know
and
a lot of people don't know they're
figuring it out and stuff i don't know
yeah i mean it's worth also remembering
that hbo max
in great part disney plus
and peacock i think launched during the
pandemic you know when there was no
theatrical business at all yeah like
nobody was going anywhere and so then
you had you know jason kolar who had
been the ceo of hulu who then took over
you know hbo max
and you know ultimately sort of warner
brothers streaming entertainment or
entertainment period it was like we're
putting all the theatrical movies on
streamers you know and the idea was to
rapidly increase the subscriber base
because that was the only bellwether of
success given the only the only game in
town the only way so the only way to
know the health of the company was how
many subscribers do you have in your
streamer because we can't get any money
in the box office and regular linear tv
is mostly just an antiquated vestige of
what it used to be so what's your
subscriber base like and that was what
it was all about and so now that we're
back in theaters to a certain degree and
now the business is beginning to find
its plateau again you're right we are
re-examining the ways in which the
business makes sense and does it make
sense to and not just get too far ahead
into the news but does it make sense to
put a 90 million dollar movie on on a
streamer as a debut
i don't know maybe not maybe if one or
warner brothers feels like hbo max is
now a robust competitor
um
you're not as desperate for those
subscribers as you used to be and is
that thing something that will convert
subscribers i don't know
um but there's also other math that
seems have been left off the ledger or
at the very least cast aside
in in an effort to just
make their number but that's
that's after a whole nother ad read
because we got one more show we have to
talk about course uh some talk about oh
i was just gonna say or is everybody
looking at 1.3 billion of top gun
maverick going oops
yeah i mean they waited like to be fair
they weren't they supposed to come out
like 2020 or something [ __ ] yeah brett
they're taking they were sitting on that
movie
i mean now they're the [ __ ] fortune
favored the bold on that one good god
they won the summer didn't they oh by a
long shot
end the year
uh um real time like i'm no
prognosticator because if you would ask
me like you know is top gun
gonna be the highest grossing movie of
the year or whatever i'd be like
ah nobody remembers that movie
uh i
said that i just wouldn't have called
[ __ ] a billion bucks go ahead bam bam
uh
last thing on
uh
pray is which we didn't call out but the
internet did is the gun
at the end of prey is the gun that the
predator gives
to danny glover at the end of predator
2. so they like tied it all in so
wonderfully
yeah except that it doesn't explain how
the predators get that gun to begin with
given that
the predator dies
at the end of this movie
although you do see in closing credits
three more predator ships approaching
earth so nori's story is not over nor is
the story of a gun over um but i did i
did confirm it with my friend who wrote
it i was like she's like yeah yeah he
goes 100
that's the gun
he's like how'd she get it how'd they
get it back he's like i'm not telling
you it's like fine
that's uh it's it's a
great flick kids go check out pray if
you haven't seen it yet
um
you know i don't do this rankin [ __ ]
like i'd put it [ __ ] shoulder to
shoulder with
the first one it's a real
great [ __ ]
you know balance one is like look at
this giant guy and then look at this
little kid like predators go after
everybody don't matter who
big people tiny people men women this is
the first time predator woman has been
the
center of a predator franchise or
um
yeah i believe so i mean i think
sonalifan
um
was uh was a big part of alien v
predator
one i know they made a sequel to that um
but i think a solo predator movie yeah
because it was it was arnold
then danny glover
and then uh robert rodriguez's
predators was like
broody
and and i'm sure there were other people
as well yeah there was always like where
to juggle with a bunch of people
um i think brody was the lead of that
one and then shane black's
um
i don't remember who i mean i know that
sterling k brown was
in the cast but i think it was another
like
helicopter full of dudes
and then one lady
alice prague
uh it was in predators is that what high
art 69er is saying
uh olivia munn was also in predators
they pointed out i don't think she was
the
she the main focus like god a predator's
trying to get me yeah i think it's
always like who's the last person to
face up against a predator and i think
this is the first that's what the movie
was about at the end of the day it's
it's you know
it's an academic christie thing still
getting gas out of that concept god
bless him says the guy who's making
clerks three but
then there were none
i was there when it all began and i was
like oh man
did you see his face the predator's face
was so cool when he took his mask off i
saw that mark
saw that movie
in the atlantic highlands movie theater
that i'm buying with my friends
all comes around
so i'm gonna [ __ ] one day i'm gonna
have dan trachtenberg come down to
atlantic island screen that [ __ ] prey
movie
in the theater so i could close my
[ __ ] predator prey loop
afterwards somebody asked like why don't
you get them on the show
because people don't like us and i'll be
honest with you people like mark people
don't like me that's why that's why i
don't get guests i guess
i feel weird bothering people but like
hey man [ __ ]
dan wants to be on the show i would love
to [ __ ] have dan on the show how
awesome was our interview like uh the
other week with the [ __ ] the editor
he was great oh my god
i was seeing feedback about that for the
next like two weeks people were like
that was dope
[ __ ] everything else do more of that
stop bitching about batgirl and do your
[ __ ] job and put it in the drums
um all right let's dive into it kids
here it is
years ago i bought the first issue of
sandman off the shelf off the [ __ ]
rack
at a comic book store uh and uh fell in
love instantly with one of the most
literate books ever met uh written one
of the most imaginative
uh books ever written i don't just mean
comic books i mean [ __ ] books uh
sandman without salmon i never would
have written [ __ ] dogma um sam man
was one of those books that made me go
like oh i want to write comics one day i
wish i was british i'll never do that
um
sandman was uh like
you know the first
piece of comic book ephemera that i
bought like graffiti designs made a
sandman statue with matthew the raven on
his shoulder it was like 125 bucks and i
bought it my mother's thought i was nuts
she was like why would you spend what
does it do it's not even a figure i was
like it's a piece of art ma it's like
the infinite prague statue you change
the outfit on the infinite prague every
season letting season and [ __ ] this is
my infinite prague i would scream with
my monk
um sam has a long way of saying sandman
has been in my life for a long long time
um sandman was the
barometer of cool like uh you passed
around to people to be like you must
read this um it bonded you
uh with with people like uh
i mean i'm not gonna say
sandman got me laid but like it was
involved in many of my relationships
like you have you read sandman and like
if somebody
vibed with it you were like well this is
somebody i want to spend
time with um
you know i i got to meet neil many times
over the years i've worked with neil he
did a voice in one of our cartoons and
stuff um he's i've had him on the
podcast uh lovely
[ __ ] dude who i was always so happy
to tell him to his face what his work
has meant to me and stuff and for years
you know we've watched
people
make runs at a sandman something you
know roger apron for years was rumored
to be doing one
most recently joseph gordon-lewis was
attached to a sandman thing
none of them ever
come to pass and stuff and then in the
age of netflix
uh even though you know as a dc comic i
believe neil owns it all right is
independently owned because of vertigo
or something um i i don't i don't know
if he does um i'm not sure what the
deals were like back in the day it is it
seems abundantly clear you couldn't do
it without him yeah without his blessing
without his sort of you know giving it
the good graces
um and they pitched like hbo passed on
it hbo didn't i don't from what i
understand didn't quite understand it
they're like do we think people are
going to watch this like i don't know do
we get it i'm not sure we get it and
then they let it go and they let it
leave warner brothers the the larger
network entity that's right because it
would have made sense if it was an hbo
thing yeah
it is
to say that you know there was some
anticipation
uh going into it uh you know after
[ __ ] three decades of loving the work
and [ __ ]
um
is an understatement i saw the trailer
first trailer when they showed them
[ __ ] drop in burgess's [ __ ] magic
circle i was like
holy [ __ ]
like
oh my god this is what you get when you
wait all this time and let the creator
be involved like it [ __ ] looked like
the book felt like the [ __ ] book at
least from the trailer
and you know i've just finished watching
all 10 episodes uh
i guess an hour before we started the
show i watched the last episode
uh what a wonderful [ __ ] journey like
i loved it i absolutely loved it um it
was like visiting with old friends
because these are stories that i've
known for three decades and
seeing them come to life you know uh not
just on the page but you know people
acting out these parts saying these
words that
have been in my heart forever since you
know i first read the comics when they
were first printed
i was an absolute thrill i felt
nothing but you know
happiness and pride for [ __ ] neil
like
he his magnum opus realized so
beautifully and he's intimately
[ __ ] involved with it and you could
see
you know the craftsmanship um in the new
medium that he took
you know from the original work uh
beautiful imaginative [ __ ] brilliant
um you know i
i watched it with somebody who had no
[ __ ] sandman
experience
my wife jennifer was just like what is
this and i was like i
i cannot prepare you for how imaginative
this is
uh but i think you'll like it and she
absolutely [ __ ] loved it you know
complete virgin she's not bringing all
the history with her of like i love this
since dot dot dot she was just like what
are we watching and you know instantly
and she watches most [ __ ] with her
laptop open
by the middle of the first episode that
laptop closed and she was just like this
for the next 10 hours it's wonderful
storytelling great direction a series of
different directors
um i'm so happy for netflix because i
think that i read a tweet from neil said
it was number one
in 59 countries this weekend so
it's got that's got to be some sort of
huge hit for them they now have
their own
comic book franchise you know to go
shoulder shoulder with uh umbrella
academy and stuff
um
it is a masterwork and
you know my only [ __ ] criticism is
like [ __ ] how long we gotta wait for
season two like
just sumptuous and beautiful uh
you know
merv pumpkinhead's animation
is pitch perfect looks like it's a guy
playing the body and then they do like
like looks like stop motion a little bit
stop motion for the [ __ ] face and
expressions like it was so captivating
um the guy who plays dream is
like he was [ __ ] cut out of the pages
um born to [ __ ] play this role even
his delivery
feels like those
[ __ ] word balloons that didn't look
like any other word balloon
black word balloons with white letters
[Music]
is is their dream was absolutely [ __ ]
wonderful
i i enjoyed joe
joanna constantine
switch from
uh john which i guess he doesn't own
john constantine so that's why they
couldn't constant time sorry [ __ ]
extended a million times in the show
um but
the
what i'm pretty sure what i saw
in that episode was
newcastle
like if you know you're constantine
history you know you're a hellblazer
reader going way back
uh new castle was the [ __ ] like
ceremony where the kid got [ __ ] taken
to hell and [ __ ] like that that haunts
john
cox
and you know
if i remember my comics history
correctly that happened first and then
neil
bid it for
for sandman
and so i was
shocked and delighted to see
what looked like a pretty [ __ ] clear
visual representation of of the
newcastle incident in her
nightmare
fantasy you know what she saw in her
nightmare and i think i was i was
watching i was like is that [ __ ] new
castle
and then i uh
the uh i think it was jamie delano who
of course worked on hellblazer echoed
the same thing on online
so yeah it was
man
you know expectations were high but
smash them you know
this is perfect i can't imagine anybody
have anything critical to say about this
[ __ ] thing
oh god
oh my god what
um
what can you possibly [ __ ] have to
say about this other than it is
wonderful
i think it is wonderful and i and i do
love it and i i similarly go back quite
a bit with sandman i don't think i
discovered in floppies
um but i definitely discovered in trades
and like the first edition of those
trades
and uh and and felt deeply madly in love
with um
it is the comic book that made me want
to write fiction
um
because of of what neil found a way to
do within the pages of that book you
know the genius of sandman is not just
how well it's executed but that he built
for himself a framework in which he
could tell whatever story he wanted to
tell
and sometimes they were long and
involving and sometimes there were these
little short little like perfect tiny
novellas of of drama or humor or
intrigue or whatever
but it's it's i think it's a masterpiece
um that said neil himself has said like
listen i don't think the book is what
the book would become i don't think i
learned how to write sandman until i
wrote the sound of her wings
he said that's that's when i found the
voice that's when i found what this book
could do
um and so before that
you know it's it's
it's a little bit rocky for me and i do
i think we texted about it early on i
was like each episode is better than the
last episode that came before it because
similarly the show is finding
its own sort of rhythms in its own way
through it
but it's
it's it's a hard dramatic place to find
yourself in where the main character of
your show
starts the show
inactive and inert
like dream doesn't do very much for that
whole first episode like they add a
whole preamble where he's trying to
track down the corinthian and holy [ __ ]
boyd holbrook is amazing as the [ __ ]
corinthian like just literally pulled
from the pages and i didn't know he had
that many teeth but every time he smiles
he's like oh that's the [ __ ]
corinthian
but the imprisonment of dream
is necessary for the story they want to
tell
which is how do you bring
a somewhat amorphous immortal being low
and so and give him a place to grow too
so you have to do that but it's also
like not a place you want to start your
show with your guy not saying a word and
just glowing naked from behind the cage
at
charles dance who i will watch do
anything because these charles [ __ ]
dance
and so like once once we're out of the
like
now i need now i'm free and i need to
return to my realm which is falling
apart and i need to collect my
my helm of office and my ruby and my
sand like once you're done with the
quest part of that narrative
it becomes the same man
that at least i fell in love with it
becomes you know men of good fortune the
hob-gatling story becomes
you know sound of her wings which breaks
me every time i encounter it
you know it is such this wonderful
heartbreaking emotional
um
just like candelabra of emotion and
kirby howell baptiste who is playing
death
is just the perfect
mixture of like
ethereal and earthly and
empathetic and sympathetic and she
reminds me of like a great nurse who
will come by and make you feel a little
bit better even though you're about to
do the worst thing that you have to do
or go through the worst thing you're
going to go through
and that story just
it is so many things all at once and
then once you're in that you know once
you come out of 24 7 the diner episode
which i also love
you know and and david phillips as john
d is just
magnificent
like
it then begins to take its own life
again and then you're in the dollhouse
stuff and then you're in fiddler's green
and then you're in the cereal convention
and all like all of it begins to swell
and like lucifer is back in it and we're
like
once you leave that first episode which
is wonky and then you get into the show
proper it for me it really really works
and i don't know what you could have
done to change it
i don't know how you adapt that
differently
to make it so that that first episode
doesn't sting quite as much
but i think that like they found the
best way to do that to solve that
problem they could and i definitely
appreciate that
but i came away from the series just
feeling this incredible sense of
gratitude
of like you guys you did the thing you
know you did the thing that they said
was impossible to do and you spent the
money where you needed to spend it and
then you still left room for just
stories of two guys who meet at a bar
and it's always just two guys meeting in
a bar that's all the story's gonna be
and it is just the stories that they
tell between each other and
the revelation that dream needs a friend
and never knew that he had one and then
you know how very dare you insinuate
that we're friends yeah he's such a he's
like i had to many times like you know
assure my wife look i know he's being a
bit of an emo [ __ ] but he is the hero
of the show like
it's kind of about
him being less pissy you know the whole
[ __ ] series the whole book like
he's you know he's very
he's very rigid
yes
you know it's it's all about dream
getting to the place where death already
is right where she realizes that like
you know they don't serve us like we
serve them like we are not here for like
well the entire reason the endless
exists
is not to make humans dance at our
fingertips but it's more to help them on
their way
it's more to to embody the things that
they want and need out of a disorderly
universe
um and to give them some sense of order
and like that's dream's story is he
eventually through lots of
preregulations and trauma and drama gets
to realize that it's not actually about
him
watching that death episode
through my eyes knowing that story
um and you know waiting for all the
beats to hit and ship and then just
seeing how they
brought it to life i mean i i was fi it
doesn't really even pay it a compliment
to say that i cried
uh but i did i was bawling all
throughout that [ __ ] episode because
beautiful is beautiful i don't give a
[ __ ] i read it over 30 years ago it
still hits just as [ __ ] hard the
notion like he's this is the first
person that he didn't first person to
humanize or personified death was the
first person to make it like a person
you'd be welcome to see
like this pragmatic like lively
young lady who then takes you into her
[ __ ] wings and takes you where you're
supposed to go and
so
i was incredibly satisfied watching it
come to life like oh my god i love this
is one of my favorite stories ever told
and i'm getting to watch it
but then i would just look over at my
wife who had no [ __ ] idea
that
that death was a thing that [ __ ] you
know he's part of a family and that's
his sister and
and they've got this relationship oh my
god it was
joyous and joyful to watch it with
somebody who didn't know [ __ ] because
the the [ __ ] pure discovery and like
you know
i love my wife don't get me wrong but
she's a pretty cool [ __ ] person
uh the whole time she's just like oh my
god this is so beautiful
like this is so imaginative like what a
what a beautiful idea
and and like she doesn't get emotional
she's not like me i cry at the job of
that
um she don't cry she got [ __ ] very
emotional like during that episode it
was joyous to watch it work on
somebody completely didn't know what the
[ __ ] they were about to get into i did
the moment he sat down on a bench and he
had that [ __ ]
roll with him and i was like oh my god
like i remember reading this i remember
every [ __ ] detail and i know what's
about to happen i was already getting
[ __ ] ready to well up because it's
just like one of my favorite pieces of
literature ever
this person that i spent my life with
didn't know what she was in for man and
my god it was glorious watching it work
on her i would suggest
if you're a sandman fan watch it with
somebody who has no [ __ ] clue it
gives you this whole other appreciation
for it where you're like yes
yes that's how [ __ ] imaginative i
kept saying throughout i was like
can you like i this is the thing that
like when we were done watching it i was
like you gotta understand
like it's been 30 years since he [ __ ]
wrote that serial convention issue
the fact that he got it from when that
first published as a pamphlet as a comic
book
all the way to this moment in time on
netflix and nobody ever did anything
similar or bit him or [ __ ] ripped it
off
amazing because now there's a bunch of
[ __ ] people watching this on netflix
going like
there was a whole serial killer
convention that's so [ __ ] weird a new
idea and it's like an idea that's been
around for 30 [ __ ] years i was so
happy for him that so much of the [ __ ]
he created that was so incredibly
original
people didn't because that that book has
inspired a lot of [ __ ] writers again
without [ __ ] sandman i don't get to
dogma
but the fact that like most of his
really precious
ideas incredible original ideas have
survived for over three decades without
people are going like oh we did a serial
killer convention you know for all i
know maybe they did it on supernatural
or some [ __ ] i don't watch everything
but
i have no awareness of it and i've been
watching
people on twitter
discover this and my wife too was like
that's the most [ __ ] up thing i've
ever seen i was like
i seen it in a comic
30 years ago man i was so happy for neil
that like nobody
stole his [ __ ] and like he gets to
present it to a modern audience who are
like
these are incredibly new ideas and i'm
like look they're incredibly new ideas
but they were incredibly new ideas three
decades ago the real miracle here is
that he was able to to keep it
preserved
that nobody [ __ ] with it we don't have
some previous version of sandman we have
to forget about or anything like that
it went from it in print
to it as a show over the course of three
decades and both
stand
side by side like both are
[ __ ] equally wonderful as far as i'm
concerned yeah and the fact that the
commentary of specifically you know the
collectors episode
of fandom
of what it means to be a fan and how the
corinthian is the embodiment of fandom
goneri
which is in this and you know not to
spoil very much if you haven't seen it
but that is precisely what dream tells a
room full of [ __ ] serial killers is
you took the wrong inspiration from this
like he was not supposed to inspire you
to evil he was supposed to reflect onto
you
the reality of what darkness could be
you know and and to be watching that in
a moment when fandom is having its own
existential crisis about who gets to be
a fan of what it means to be a fan and
who allows
you know
certain people to participate in their
fandom or not you know does fandom get
to be as brutal and awful and racist and
misogynist and sexist as it is if they
hadn't taken the wrong message from the
very heroes that they attempt to emulate
like guys there's a dark side for a
reason and it wasn't to inspire you to
join the dark side
um
but i love that all of that is still
part of it and you know neil having been
a member of the comics community for a
long time knew it as well as anybody
knew it in the in the late 80s early 90s
and still knows it as well as anybody
knows it today
um
i think it's i think it's a majestic
piece of work
um that that becomes what it needs to be
as it goes on and that is not
by a lack of talent of anybody's you
know part like alan heinberg who uh who
was the showrunner and neil and david
goyer who created it all together and
all of their writers and all their
directors and the casting people i mean
my god like
there's there's not one bad note in any
person who's on that show you know from
from the people i've never seen before
like the actress blank rose walker who i
think is fantastic
to boy holbrook as a corinthian to
stephen fry as fiddler's green
to sarah niles as rosemary spoilers
gilbert
gilbert hmm
i'd honestly forgotten that aspect of
the story and then like at one point i
was like
and i was like do you know who gilbert
is
he's like no but i could tell you want
to tell me i'm like he's not a person
he's a place
like that
um and then just moments of grace like
there there there are just moments in
this thing where
you know he's he's
unmaking nightmares with a sense of of
pity and like the gregory scene
when he's got to come in like i need
something that was just of my creation
that exists in the dreamy that hasn't
left and cain and abel you worded a
story before there was a dreaming and so
i can't really claim to you but
gregory is mine and he's gotta
ultimately euthanize
a dog
um it's done with such care and such
kind of empathy and sympathy even though
it's a it's a cruel act
but this is a show that finds the way
to make those things play without it
feeling
as if you're just being brutal for
brutality's sake i mean
death
is there for the death of a baby
you know and like and it's just
like that was my wife on the couch going
no and i looked over and i was like soon
you know because
if you don't know the if you don't know
the book
that's not the first thing that occurs
to you right so they show a mother
putting a kid you know into the crib and
so i think where my wife's head went was
like oh the mother's going to die
and then when like when death picks up
the baby that was when she was like no
and i was like already in tears and i
was like yeah
oh yeah i was like let's see if they do
what they did in the books and they
[ __ ] did if i remember correctly in
the books she had a little conversation
with the kid and i think the kid spoke
like didn't the babies ask death a
question death responded i think i could
be wrong the actual book um in this they
had death talk to the kid but the kid
didn't talk to death she was just
responding to a question we didn't hear
yeah and it's just the crying stops
like the sound of the baby crying is
present in the scene until it's not
and then death picks up the baby and
then has that conversation whatever but
it's just
it's it is just so beautiful and even in
you know moments of the episodes that i
didn't love as much as i love the latter
episodes there's still moments of grace
and wonder and awe
that get at what makes a man so [ __ ]
special oh my god and [ __ ] everything
else the most metal version of hell ever
presented in a
film's medium like seriously think of a
better hell oh my god they showed dis
like and it looked and the gates of dis
had a gigantic [ __ ]
upside down star dude there's a ram with
giant [ __ ] like goat heads and [ __ ]
like it was
it was just so metal as [ __ ] like just
like look like an album cover oh my god
and i love that like the courtyard of
lucifer's castle alice whatever it is
is ultimately like saint peter's square
in the vatican that's now just filled
with fire and bodies and and demons and
like wow you guys [ __ ] went for it
yeah
he did they they spared no expense they
built a very memorable
[ __ ] hell even their crowd scenes man
when you look down at all the [ __ ]
thousands of dukes of hell and [ __ ] like
that it was it was impressive it looked
[ __ ] really good
yeah looking show man and
you know thank god they waited till this
point in time because now they got the
tools to do it properly
who knows would have been like 20 years
ago not that
no no it would have been like the best
x-files episode
which not that they're bad
but they're small
you know
like there's there's next generation
episodes that want to feel big but
couldn't even though they were working
at the height of technology at the time
but you just you couldn't have achieved
that
maybe not even 10 years ago on
television but here we are
um
yeah man it was uh it's absolutely
[ __ ] wonderful it's worth your time
kids each episode is almost an hour
there's ten it's definitely a day or a
two-day commitment depending if you
start late at night
um but [ __ ]
it's
it's just you know
what's that song from willy wonka it's
just pure imagination
um delightful heartbreaking
thrilling
funny and awry sort of way
just wonderful performances
it's nothing about it is a waste of
anybody's time
yeah
i want more and i think they're gonna
make more how could that not how could
they not [ __ ] green light a season
two with yes that's it seems to be
enjoying
it couldn't happen to a nicer guy too
neil is such a [ __ ] sweetheart
yeah he's he's always been incredibly
gracious
and kind when i've interacted with him
you know both personally and
professionally as a journalist as a fan
as a comic book writer
as a dude who just asks for favors
occasionally i'm like hey man did you
quote my book absolutely
some folks in chat are asking us to
mention um
uh
well david something in chat said the
door is a giant pentagram a bit too much
no [ __ ] that ain't hell
that is hell that's what it [ __ ]
should be hella wait [ __ ]
uh a lot of people have said like hey
man what about uh nobody's mentioning
the audible version of salmon there is
an audible sandman audio
podcast uh and in which merv pumpkin
head is not portrayed by the great mark
hamill who was wonderful
uh in uh netflix's and sandman but is
portrayed by a lesser known
lesser revered
fairly
controversial for the weirdest [ __ ]
reasons
sometime actor a name of kevin smith
uh and it's a very faithful adaptation
of the book uh i would say in the
netflix version they've taken they've
had to take some liberties um he's
compressed some things into others and
whatnot uh but it's pretty faithful
but you know they're
little things have been
turned or changed for the episodic
nature of storytelling
yeah as well as because
as you intimated earlier they don't have
the rights to everything dc
that had been in the first you know
eight episodes
of the show
like lida and hector hall if i remember
correctly
like wasn't hector hall the original
sandman
and that's something that they didn't
say touch on or anything he was just a
guy he's just a guy lida was married to
and stuff um
they did show a representation with with
uh jetty with rose walker's brother
of a hero costume very
sandman reminiscent calling himself the
sandman and stuff and his rogues gallery
there were like hey that looks like
captain cold hey that looks like you
know and there were some dc
icons
placed throughout i saw some of the
episodes
um
but yeah like john d was kept in arkham
asylum which they couldn't gandhi was
was dr destiny from the [ __ ] justice
league he's a
[ __ ] b c d list justice league
villain with his [ __ ] magic rock and
[ __ ] like that that they fought
for decades long before neil
co-opted him and brought him into the
sandman story and told this like epic
[ __ ] tale which we watched in in the
episode that they did man i think they
called it 24 7.
um you know i remember reading that
issue and [ __ ] like watching
the waitress [ __ ] stab her eyes with
[ __ ] steel needles and him just
creating [ __ ] chaos and [ __ ] so yeah
it wasn't dr destiny
you can get away with calling a guy john
d and it's not like hey that's [ __ ]
dc comics owns that and there was it was
the story was none the poorer for it
david nicholas was just absolutely
wonderful and the story that neil
found to tell with his character to time
into burgess was all
like i liked i was like that all [ __ ]
tracks for me that's all [ __ ] great
in a world where he can't be doctor
destiny that's [ __ ] just as good if
not better yeah so all of his fixes
completely
worked as well but yeah some [ __ ] he he
don't own so he couldn't
he couldn't necessarily [ __ ] with hence
joanna constantine as opposed to john
constantine
um but man oh man [ __ ] what good
times
kids
walk don't run
don't sleep on the sandman
ah nice job
thank you uh those are all our reviews
that's it my friend
there it is we gave you a bunch of
reviews kids uh and now
we go from reviews over to the news but
first before that we does blue chews
no more rhyming i mean it right man [ __ ]
it blue chew
is the proud sponsor of the second half
this year's second half of uh fat man
beyond ladies and gentlemen blue chew
uh you wanna follow along man you wanna
you wanna
you wanna get involved in a special deal
man listen to this
and then we'll tell you the rest of this
[ __ ] just follow along go to uh
blue chew man bluechew.com
right now
uh enter the promo code fat man at
checkout you're just gonna pay five
dollars shipping that's it that's
bluechew.com promo code fatman receive
your first month free
visit bluejo bluechu.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank the bluetooth folks for
sponsoring the podcast blue chew is what
exactly mark
well blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever the opportunity
is
processed
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online no visit to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations with other
people sitting in the waiting room and
waiting in line at the pharmacy and they
are prepared and shipped direct to your
door made in the good old us today in a
discreet package
so hey man
you can be excited to see the postman
and i don't mean that the the old kevin
costner will be i mean the guy who's
delivering you your dick pills
so
if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and as kevin said we
got a special deal for our listeners if
you tried blue chew free
when you use our promo code fatman at
checkout you just pay five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
fatman to receive your first month free
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and we as
always thank bluechu for sponsoring this
year podcast we absolutely do
temperatures aren't the only thing could
be rising this summer kids
could be you
with blue chew
go to bluechu.com fat man we thank the
good folks of blue chew for sponsoring
the news
portion of this episode of fat man
beyond what news mark look at the news
what
what news breaks um well okay listen we
are not going to re-litigate what has
been litigated quite a bit on the
internet this past week in the wake of
um warner brothers discovery deciding to
shelve both uh and by shelf i mean never
release never to be seen by the light of
day both batgirl and scoob
the scooter yeah you know
we i i i of course talked about batgirl
at great lengths over at hollywood
babylon if you're interested in what i
had to say
which i did not feel was very
controversial at all nor do i think it
was very aggro at all uh you can go
watch that elsewhere on the channel and
stuff but i would like to take a moment
for for scoob to pour one out for the
scoob what was it holiday special or
halloween special or i believe something
to that effect
uh because animation
takes way longer
to put together than live action so
these cats been working on scoob
probably
four years or more
and that's four years your life and yeah
you're getting paid and stuff like that
i get it like you know i as mentioned
i i was working on strange adventures
some people were like oh he [ __ ] they
didn't make strange adventures and
that's why he's all salty about batgirl
i didn't think i was salty about batgirl
uh but those two things don't correlate
i got paid to write strange adventures
and you know whenever you get hired for
these jobs there's like zero expectation
they move beyond script you know
everyone's horny for a project in script
stage but then when they've paid for it
and they've come so to speak then
they're like
i don't know if i want this anymore and
they don't necessarily always make it
and being that i've been in the business
for three decades you know i was like
look i'm happy to write this thing and
i'd be happy if i could direct it but
it's probably not going to happen and as
predicted it didn't happen instead so i
wasn't bitter about it at all
i got paid
but it was one thing i did that year
amongst
30 other things that i also did
these some cats have been working on
scoob for four years and that's it
like just that and and the general
satisfaction one gets of like ah all
that time i worked on a thing they're
gonna see that thing
um has been removed completely so this
is not me
tearing anybody a new one this is me
very calmly saying
like pour one out for the good folks who
put all their time in on scoob i just
read a story where
they had already paid for
the musicians and they'd already paid
for the soundstage so they recorded
their score anyway the other day even
though nobody will ever see the movie
and that was kind of
that's really sad to hear but again this
is not me going like smith on a terror
against
i got no skin in the game right but yeah
well bad for a bunch of people that
worked on a thing
that they're like well
i guess i could tell you about it
yeah i mean i i the thing about batgirl
that i that i mostly feel
is that like
yeah i get it there's there's there's a
new king in town and very often in
hollywood what happens is the new guy
kind of kicks everything that the old
guys the old regime had done off to the
side you know shows that have been going
very often get canceled things that were
in development and on the runway to
production don't happen because the new
person wants to do whatever the new
person wants to do and doesn't want to
be saddled with either the failures of
or sometimes even worse not be able to
take credit for the successes of what
had come before
but i will say
that there does seem to be a bit of
short side this in the feeling about
batgirl which
apparently a very early version had
screened
um with tech visual effects and attempt
score and it landed you know the test
screen came back and it scored in the
low
60s which apparently not great they like
things to score in the 80s or the 90s
much like you know a parent and a kid in
school
but the thing to remember is that
lots of films at this particular stage
don't score that well because there's an
audience who just doesn't know how to
look at a work print and not see what
looks like shitty effects and crappy
music and all that stuff
and so apparently black adam and shazam
fury of the gods have both tested
in the 60s most recently and nine of
those movies are being canceled now what
makes
either of them feel more like theatrical
plays than batgirl does one of them has
the rock i get it sure that dude's a
movie star not so sure about shazam but
that's not a hero there the thing that i
think is short-sighted
is to not understand
that
there was an audience that dc has only
ever been able to tap into once that
they don't seem that interested in which
is
women
and like
i was not the biggest fan of captain
marvel in the world
but that movie made a billion dollars
why because it was the first marvel
movie about a female character in the
league
you muted
are you sure that's why i made a billion
i my wife told me is because the mall
rats reference
it was also that
the difference maker was
stan lee reading a mall rat script we
all know how well
mall rats did his you know at the box
office and clearly
uh yeah good point i hadn't thought
about that but i ain't gonna say [ __ ]
because i'm getting yelled at about
batgirl anymore over to you yes and so
not only did you have
a female audience who would have rallied
to [ __ ] see batgirl but you had a uh
latino latina latinx audience who would
have rallied to see themselves on screen
in a giant [ __ ] warner brothers
superhero
um
it feels as if like whatever the 90
million dollars they get to write down
as a tax expense
might have been
superseded by the upside that they could
have made in the box office by giving an
underserved audience what they want
um
that is just me as a consumer that is me
as a as a writer producer and now
apparently director but more than that
that is me as a person who's been
looking at the sort of trends and the
waves and the way that the audience has
begun to mature and and metastasized
over the last 10 years or so
that if people have do not get to see
themselves often and are never
represented on screen and the way they'd
like to see it and you give them that
they will show up
you know and does it matter that you
know
whatever their giant corporate strategy
is for dc which makes no sense
until it makes sense
which is the joker made a billion
dollars that's great but then we have
all these other movies that don't seem
to build towards anything we have four
different batmans and we're dropping
this batman from this movie and adding
that batman and there's a couple of
different flashes ones on tv one's in in
the movies with there's a cyborg that
may or may not happen we may never have
a green lantern show like all of these
things just seem like chaos and they're
the slap dash multiverse that bc has
sort of built um that doesn't have the
the same streamlined continuity that
marvel's multiverse does and it's not to
say one versus the other
but
there is no plan here other than now
to just sort of
blast holes in what had been there
before
and of all the things to blast holes in
it seems as if batgirl was maybe the one
to leave intact
and to roll the dice time
that's just me that's not kevin at all
saying anything he's not liberating
lacerating puncturing
defenestrating castrating it doesn't
matter mark i'm gonna get blamed for it
anyway like i didn't last time and all
the headlines were smith burns the very
earth below the ground of da da da banff
man save us here i was just gonna say
as a 41 year old
white guy who's not underrepresented
anywhere i would have shown up just
because
my batman was in that movie and the
batgirl suit was cool enough to spend 15
bucks on even if the movie was terrible
like you would have gotten my money
just on those two things
and i think there's probably
a lot of people out there that would
have done the same
yeah i mean i don't think quality has
ever necessarily been the barometer of
box office success
exhibit a there was a godzilla versus
king kong movie that's awful that still
made like 800 million dollars at the box
office
you know
not to say that this movie was bad could
have been not to say it was great also
could have been but i think the
financial upsides were such that it
might have been worth a roll of the dice
that sadly we will never get to see
i i'm trying to
i would love to express something
without fear of it being turned into
click-baity headlines
yes
this is not me
excoriating anybody this is not me
telling any studio how to do their job
um one of the things i'll miss about
this batgirl movie is i i don't i heard
it was only three scenes i read online
but
i i very much am looking forward to
michael keaton's return as batman i
don't think he should be the universe's
only batman i was a big fan of a guy
i've worked with a few times in other
shows who wound up playing batman as
well um one who continues to play batman
as we just heard last week he's coming
back for aquaman two but
as banff man pointed out like you know i
was there for 1989
you know tim burton's batman michael
keaton in the suit so
this
like hey let's bring michael keaton back
to play
you know
i i i was looking forward to every
instance of it i'm going to miss
seeing the one that was already shot
that's not me being angry
that's that's not me
[ __ ]
bitching or or
tearing anybody a new one i'm just
i would like to see more michael keaton
as batman
and there you have it let's see what the
internet
does with that mark
yeah you know and then the fact that
the new head of warner brothers
discovery
um
has uh apparently very bullish on this
new flash move
um
even though
as apparently we cannot go a week
without
another installment of our
uh ezra miller is apparently allegedly
an [ __ ]
um which we might be able to drop the
apparently allegedly now that he is uh
has been charged with felony burglary in
vermont
um
like
i don't know how they keep sticking with
that movie other than they spent 150
million dollars on it already
but
the fact that we keep kind of dancing
around the fact that like
as long as this dude is still being i'm
sorry as long as this person is still
being this person out in the world
i don't see how you release a movie
starring this person
um
the the the idea of recasting uh has
been floated at the very least by me but
i have to imagine it taking place in
some corridors of power over there
um
and i guess deemed too expensive
to reshoot a decent chunk of this movie
with a different performer
um but i still don't know how you
release it
i just told them the high mana press
tour i still don't know how you me maybe
the audience at large is like might not
care
but that's the narrative
of this movie at this point
and
if you don't make a clean break and just
reshoot redesign his
you know the flash's costume so that
there's a helmet instead of an open face
and so all of that speed force stuff
just we don't got to worry about that
that's just flash and then you just need
a new actor for talking [ __ ]
i don't know man you can have that movie
out by december but
at this rate
it seems like they dropped the wrong
superhero movie into a pit
um
let's see uh
yeah no that's not even want to talk
about i don't even do it as i just get
filled for like
it's so weird i get yelled at and and
and like made fun of by people for
having an opinion
but they seem to escape the irony that
they also haven't been
uh so i i ain't saying [ __ ] anymore
other than
you know hey man
i love comic book movies
um i will say this though um
about to speak big mark
[Laughter]
um we talked about the aforementioned uh
cancelled strange adventures i was not
aware of the fact that when on hollywood
babylon i was like um
oh they're not doing strange adventures
hey
i thought i was telling people about a
project they didn't even know existed
but then i saw a bunch of articles going
well now strange adventures is cancelled
i'm like
you knew about this like i had no idea
because it was so hush-hush they were
like you can't [ __ ] talk about this
if you [ __ ] talk about then batman's
gonna throw you off the roof like they
were super like on lockdown about
so when i said on babylon i was like
yeah i worked on a thing and now that's
gone too and [ __ ] and i didn't [ __ ]
about i was just like this is the thing
that happened
um
i had no idea that that
a that the world knew about it and b
that i was announcing
that it was canceled i thought
i thought i was announcing a thing they
didn't know existed was never going to
exist instead i guess somebody had done
an article at some point so
um
people have asked i talked about a
little bit on babylon i won't do it all
again here you can go watch it over at
babylon if you're that interested but i
was going to do an episode that featured
uh jimmy olsen perry white and and
bizarro uh as we've talked about or i
talked about on babylon uh nick cage was
going to be our
our guy we made no deal so i'm not
saying he signed on the dotted line
that's who we were going for uh our
perry white
which we were you know
i was going for john goodman
above
were
had different
thoughts
there was this not my idea but somebody
was just like
could be that harrison ford is
interested we were like
you know
um
our jimmy cause me and eric uh crosco
wrote this together uh was uh uh the kid
on uh
on cobra kai
who i absolutely love is it miguel is
this character miguel
i'll take your word for it i have never
seen a cobra guy you never saw a cobra
car yeah that's a wonderful ship um i i
i don't know his name in real life
solo maybe i don't know but this guy's
playing blue beetle now yes yeah that's
the guy who's playing blue beetle when
we saw that he got cast his blue beetle
we were like [ __ ] because that one's
jimmy olsen
um or the one we the person we wanted
yes there's jimmy olsen again
no deals or anything like that in place
um but
the the our representation of bizarro
like when
jimmy and and
perry first got to bizarro world
um
bizarro presented as nick cage
via george reeves superman so it was
essentially nick cage in
the old george reeves costume
and
you know he was very you know g shucks
and
give the performance
very you know
chris reeve slash
early comics version of the character
and then slowly throughout the show
you know as you would see this kind of
perfect idealized world starts crumble
and
and people weren't as happy as they were
presenting working for
their version of the daily planet and
you know uh this guy was like an angry
child god who would just [ __ ] kill at
will and
there's a slow resistance that builds up
against their superman and they start
putting backwards s's up everywhere and
[ __ ] like that
so
um eventually you know he totally decays
like over the course of the show as he
stresses he starts turning into what we
know as
[ __ ] bizarro and then he kills
somebody and [ __ ] takes their blood
and
paints the ass backwards across his
chest because he's being the monster and
then he speaks
like you know normally throughout all
that until he starts
you know breaking down and then he's
just like me
um
angry like you know he's starting to
charlie and algernon if i may borrow
from the book and the movie and stuff
so uh eventually he goes full bizarro
and uh uh the
bizarro world
uh
collapses we think it doesn't in the ps
we find out and stuff but he is stranded
here
and you know he goes [ __ ] crazy he's
trying to kill jimmy olsen and perry
[ __ ] white
and uh eventually like
he
he's he's about to kill him but then
because of his actions some kid is put
in danger and kid is hanging from the
edge of a building like help help
and he finally gets the chance to be the
hero
that he always wanted to be
so
you know then at the end like he gets
crushed by the falling giant [ __ ]
soldier that toyman had left there
before the episode began
and you think he's dead but then they
move the rubble and [ __ ] and he's like
he's not there
so
this is the the last scene i don't even
know like what the rules are on
something like this
um
you know like
it's never going to get made so what the
[ __ ] right like they can't take the
money away
yeah they already paid me and [ __ ] but
it could be like they didn't pay me for
silence
and i'm not like giving it away or
anything but
this was the last uh scene which we were
kind of uh happy with you know we've
went on this whole [ __ ] adventure and
superman's not part of the deal
so part of the job was like you know
these are the characters you get to play
with so i got to play with the daily
planet and the staff there but i
couldn't play with
lois clark and superman
um but
they told us like you could try
to sneak them in at the end
so this is how
it would have ended and stuff uh
the
you know we don't we hear about lois and
clark the whole episode they've gone off
to washington to cover a story so
they're not around
for this adventure and stuff and so on
page six and four the script says as the
editorial staff
um
all turn to the source of the voice we
pull back over the unseen lois lane as
she definitely balances a tray of
coffees in one hand while holding up the
daily planet with the other headline to
camera uh she says but writing this good
means you can get along just fine
without me barry blushes proudly at our
jimmy practically as our jimmy
practically leaps from a seat to help uh
miss lois lane he goes welcome back miss
lane he takes tray coffee from her uh
jimmy looks over her shoulder
and then he goes where's mr kent
and so
uh the point perry wrote a story for the
first time in years
and that's the story that she was
complimenting it on and so jimmy's like
where's mr ken
rush to black credits roll and roll but
we're not finished yet like any big
super air event there's a little bit
more exterior
the arctic day
bright sun over endless white the ice
reflects the sky an infinite space a ver
and very small in the landscape
is bizarro a polar bear turns its head
to watch and pass
it might be the fiercest killer in the
animal kingdom bizarro pays no mind it's
a reference to an old work of mine
closer to see he is trudging through the
snow not hovering he's walking his feet
finally touching the ground
this is his penance this is exile but
then
a few yards behind bizarro iconic red
boots hit the snow
like a point guard touching down from a
three-point shot hell yeah we know from
those boots this is finally finally the
real thing it's him
the man of steel bizarro turns filled
with absolute religious terror he
tightens up unsure if punishment awaits
and we hear the superman we don't see
him we just hear the voice because we
can't show
but we hear the voice of authority and
superman says i read in the planet what
you did with jimmy olsen and perry white
and i just wanted to say thank you and
bizarro cox's head like a spaniel again
this is the most sincere thanks he has
ever received you know people were
always thanking him from zara world but
they were forced to and superman is
looking out at the view and he goes
i like to come up here too it's nice to
be alone sometimes
but it's better to have a friend
and he extends this and he says hi
my name is cal
and bizarro looks at the hand extended
in friendship he takes it and shakes it
solemnly and superman goes
but most people call me and bizzaro's
cracked face breaks into a smile a kid
at christmas and he says
superman
the end come on [ __ ]
my one question yeah
uh i'd like to know who wrote
the line
he touches down like a point guard after
a three-point shot
because i don't think that was you oh
eric
like that sounds like a sports ball oh
my god i as i read it i didn't even know
what it meant i was like i i hope i'm
reading this correctly
mine is definitely hard um
yeah strange adventures promised to be a
[ __ ] really dope show ours was one
segment it was an anthology every
episode was like a different mini movie
like an
hour-long dc movie that like
investigated
other characters that weren't batman
wonder woman superman and stuff aquaman
just all the fringe man they gave me a
list of characters to choose from from
that had boston bran on it dead man uh
believe me i wanted to take that but i
was like i'd [ __ ] that up this i figured
i could do right though and it gave me
like a one more chance one more bite at
that superman apple where i was like oh
[ __ ] maybe i'll get to play with big red
after all
but didn't happen and again
not please don't write smith
[ __ ] hurt crying outrage smith
understands completely from the jump
when sarah schechter was like this show
is going to cost 16 to 20 million
dollars the first thing i said was like
i can't imagine that will ever come to
pass
like that seems like a lot of money for
for like ip that not everybody knows but
again
this was when the streaming wars were
heating up this is when hbo max was just
opening its doors and they're like we're
going to throw [ __ ] everything at the
wall we're just going to make content
galore because this is the future people
are you know we're going to be covered
with disease forever outside
only going to be able to stream
so that was the only
thin window that's what sarah told me
she was like they're making these shows
she's like it's there's no two ways
about it so like they're spending the
money they they want to compete
so you know i always took it with a
grain of salt and [ __ ] i've been
involved in like kingdom keepers and
disney play i know how quickly things
can just
go away and [ __ ] so i ain't mad that it
went away i was always kind of
incredulous at whatever happened in the
first place once i heard those budgets
and [ __ ]
i was like honestly like because i was
like yeah i can direct like a three four
million dollar [ __ ] stand-alone story
they're like three four million no no no
because i have no expense i was used to
the cw budgets for the like we're
spending [ __ ]
crazy pilot money you know like [ __ ]
game of thrones money i was like what
the [ __ ]
so you know the fact that it's not
happening i'm not like
but it could have been cool could have
been very cool and life's long who knows
one day perhaps me and eric were like
instantly were like well eric more than
me was like let's call the comics let's
call dc and do it as a comic book and i
was like here you go if they'll just
manufacture for use at least they'll
find a home and stuff it's a good story
there's some really good writing in it
man i was proud of what he did i was
proud of what i did and [ __ ] is some
good [ __ ]
excellent it was like you know honestly
it was kind of like
up
in in
in dc like
old man young kid having an adventure
you know
yeah anyway so
uh
other there must be other news out there
you know
there is there's not a time um there is
because this swallowed up an entire news
cycle yeah
you know i will say there was some andor
news that came with the trailer that
dropped
um
a little while ago that a trailer was
[ __ ] wonderful that trailer looks
amazing i mean honestly like once again
you could probably hear me on this very
show months ago being like i don't know
i don't give a [ __ ] about andor i guess
i'll watch it it's free don't cost
nothing
that [ __ ] trailer made me go like
i
i want this so [ __ ] badly like holy
[ __ ]
yeah it looks [ __ ] good really um
according to showrunner tony gilroy who
was also one of the the people credited
with one the show will go for two
seasons long and then the last scene
will butt up against the beginning of
rogue one oh that's kind of cool yeah um
pony is the tony i mean he's he's kind
of i don't know if he's taken credit for
it yet but tony is the one that brought
us
that darth vader sequence at the end of
rogue one
he's the guy that came in and was like
let's do this at the end and you know
it's [ __ ] one of the greatest [ __ ]
star wars sequences in
history one thing i noticed from all
those stories that came out about me
talking about batgirl
um and you know granted it was on
hollywood babylon which is a [ __ ]
nightclub comedy show where were
to make people laugh and [ __ ] not really
a hard news show um
but i curse an awful lot
i i
i curse like an inarticulate man like my
i cursed my full head off because i read
all my comments written back in articles
and i'm like
my god can i
think of another word other than [ __ ]
as a modifier just
it's always [ __ ] just [ __ ] saying
[ __ ]
thank god it's made a handsome living
for me mark speaking of handsome you
haven't said anything about my gorgeous
roosevelt shirt that i'm wearing
into the collaboration of kevin smith
collaboration go to roosevelts.com you
can buy it under that
i'm wearing a
spirit jersey movies shirt i'm a [ __ ]
fashion template
with collab wear mark people [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] i don't think you commented
on my t-shirt
that was a collab we did last year with
the hundreds see
i'm wrapping them up i've read them i
read online for the last few days how
like i've lost my edge and i'm not hip
and blah blah blah bunch of people
attacking me and [ __ ] like that usual
customers but uh
you know
i don't know i feel pretty limp with all
these collabs
roosevelt spirit jersey i mean
bamboo right for an old man
not bad hey it's banff man everybody
what's up i don't have kevin smith
clothing on now but i'll share a story
that
uh jen
will look at me and she'll be like
we're going out for dinner you are not
allowed to wear a scum and villainy hat
a scum and villainy t-shirt and a scum
and villainy sweatshirt and i was like
kevin does it and that's how he sells
merch like
what i'm a walking billboard
that's a missed opportunity for you to
be out you got a business kid
for you to be out there in that world
not even on the down low hustling that
business putting that name out there
building brand awareness simply by
wearing the [ __ ] that you're gonna wear
anyway that's that's foolhardy and it's
free like i don't have to pay for that
stuff
exactly
i will say i do do do this i have these
business cards made
that have free drinks on the back
so when i'm out at like home depot and i
see somebody that has like a rebel
alliance signal symbol or like a
grosgoose bumper sticker i stick it on
their windshield hoping that one day
they'll
stop by the bar
nice
that's a man door girl i like how you
got horse sense when it comes to
business that's why your business works
well man you're [ __ ] deeply invested
in it
and you're willing to like go the
distance some people are like oh i leave
work at work you [ __ ] bring work home
and [ __ ] like
and you wear your work you created a
[ __ ] thing from scratch that's yours
ain't no reason you shouldn't be wearing
t-shirts and hats [ __ ] extolling the
virtues of
everywhere everywhere at the wedding i
say
see if you can pull that [ __ ] off i wore
i wore jordan a hoodie at my wedding and
a jane sandbob t-shirt
and i'm not proud of that i'm not saying
everyone should do that
i'm seeing it i'm not saying you
should not a bad not a badge of honor
but it's just imagination but we're
still together that's got to mean
something
clothes don't necessarily make the man
although in this case
roosevelt's shirt and the spirit jersey
well
and you were too busy being fascinated
with if you could you didn't stop to
think about whether you should that's
true
[Laughter]
um all right so what else we got uh the
last piece of news um is is a sad one
because that seems to be the cycle that
we are just in
but uh michelle nichols passed away
since the last time we podcasted
um
the the great michelle nichols who
played
uhura
uh excuse me on star trek the classic
series and in a bunch of different
movies
um
you know she changed the face of
television um as we know it she has you
know the first interracial kiss on tv
was her and william shatner
um
you know the role has seen her you know
she became a sort of spokesperson for
nasa and helped recruit scientists and
astronauts
um martin luther king jr the reverend
doctor himself um
you know the story as she tells it very
well and you can find it online is she
was about to quit the show until
you know she was at an naacp convention
and
martin luther king you know rolled up on
her and said listen i'm a fan of the
show we watch the show on the road when
we're going speaking engagements and
it's vitally important that you remain
because we need to see
that there are black people in the
future
and that had never been a thing on
television before
and it's important to know that there's
a tomorrow
waiting for us even if it's fictional
even if it's fantasy and on television
but even just having that in the heads
and in the hearts of people in the world
is important
and uh and she was a fixture at
conventions you know
up until a couple years before she
passed
um and always sort of preaching that
gospel
she was on comic book men she did an
episode of comic book men with with my
friends and uh
i saw i saw the picture of she was
lovely
i met her at a few cons and she was
always so sweet and wonderful
um
but yeah right living history yeah like
she she was there for quite a bit of it
and she was there to watch as pop
culture changed in lots of different
ways um and you know to embrace the
quite literal next generation as well as
the figurative next generation of people
who grew up and would then be born to
grow into loving star trek you were a
big uh next-gen guy like did they all
eventually show up on next generation
did she show up on next generation too
um
she did not
um i think the only people to show up on
next generation were were leonard nimoy
spock had a couple of different
appearances
um before us kelly he was on the pilot
expert holly
um and then james boone showed up for an
episode as scott
um and and kirk crossed over in the
movies right generations was the kirk
picard
sort of you know the
tooth for adventure where you know tooth
vista jim kirk and cerebral uh you know
jean-luc picard got to go on one big
adventure um but to the best of my
knowledge michelle nichols never
appeared
in the next generation
um much too much too many children
um uh what an absolute legend man
absolute
as we say on uh
on
hollywood babylon huge bucket
of wind
indeed some people think it's wind it's
not win it's win meaning she won she won
all the things what a legend what an
icon and what a loss how old
um in mid 80s i believe it was like 88
years old she passed
long life but still again you figure
legends and icons should get at least a
hundred
i mean
that's the rule going forward i think
yeah i'll take that
so give me something to shoot for
uh speaking of uh
um
losing legends you know not really a
genre star although she was in
[Music]
two of a kind which is a movie about
people that die and come back you know
from [ __ ] heaven get one more chance
at life so i guess that kind of counts
as sci-fi
uh olivia newton-john passed away
indeed
uh absolute 70s icon of our childhood uh
greece uh
greece
it was just greece right well she wasn't
in a bunch of movies was she uh greece
zamasu oh nana dude what am i [ __ ]
thinking yeah greece xanadu
[ __ ]
two of a kind i think it was called that
song twist of fate when her and john
travolta got back together
um for a movie um yeah and of course a
huge recording artist
a big part of my childhood my mother
played olivia newton-john's albums while
she made sunday morning breakfast she
made eggs for all of us and [ __ ] after
church
and she'd be playing have you ever been
mellow or whatever
so she was a big part of my childhood i
texted my mom to be like oh my god mom
olivia newton-john
passed away my mom hadn't known i was
the first one to tell her and she took
it as if we lost a relative
he's always a big fan
yeah my mistake on nashon nichols was 89
years old when she passed
89.
good lord man
what a long life i hope it was happy
certainly was legendary
absolutely
fingers crossed she boldly went where
no man had gone before
[Music]
thank you that's the news my friend
that's all the news we got that's all
the news we got look at that kids give
it up for mark you gave it a [ __ ]
news man uh as we approach our [ __ ]
three of the show good lord
uh let's uh dive into the q a portion
shall we indeed
ojc
bamf bam
what you got there banff man um
i just shout out to a couple people in
chat one all the people who have been
writing kevin smith click bait headlines
in chat tonight they've been wonderful
i've seen that the other thing i've
liked in chat tonight are all the uh
predator verses
people have just periodically listing
predator verses and like
it's the most ludicrous [ __ ] i need to
you know [ __ ] anytime we talked about
something predator versus that i said
one made me laugh was predator versus
walt flanagan and then like a minute
later and said
predator versus wall flannigan versus
walt flannigan's dog
um but yes all the clickbait headlines i
saw kids and i appreciate it made me
smile uh inside i'm sure some of them
will be used
by news outlets
uh i i tried to stay out of trouble
tonight
the uh
sasquatch jenkins said uh
when you guys started talking about
sandman
anyone else watch something and think i
can't wait for mark to tell me all the
bad things about this that i missed
to be fair mark's reaction
did not belie the the review that
followed like when you know when i was
like who could [ __ ] criticize this
and he put up his hand you know you'd
think he was like this [ __ ] thing but
you know he was like the first episode's
a little slow the rest is amazing so
yeah i think it was leaner that's a rave
mark
other than
other than top gun which did get 100
rave no ifs ands or buts you were like
unequivocal yeah you really you wouldn't
[ __ ] tarantino did you see his review
i did and that's when you know it's a
slow news week when it's quentin
tarantino said he liked a movie in
public
and suddenly that's articles that's not
the i don't think that's the case
anymore i think it's because quentin
is now doing a podcast and so now you
get to hear his thoughts more than you
ever heard them before he doesn't have
to wait until he's promoting a movie now
he could just sit on a podcast and tell
you how good you know [ __ ] top gun 2
was so
i you know look
in a world where everything i say winds
up on comicbook.com thank you
comicbook.com
you make my mom think i'm famous
um you know it stands to reason that if
quentin says something cool like that on
a podcast of course it's going to get
like covered to [ __ ] death and stuff
so i i get that we're gonna see a lot
more of that
i think so i look forward to the quentin
comes out with his opinion of kevin
smith also buying a movie theater
it's true he did it first i mean look he
made movies first i i honestly don't
make the movies i make were not for
quentin like seeing [ __ ] reservoir
dogs in the theater and being like
oh my god it count this counts as movie
dialogue you can just talk about like
[ __ ] madonna lyrics and [ __ ] i'm
going to talk about star wars movies
and then also [ __ ] you like kicked me
in the pants uh when i saw pulp fiction
at the very first screening
uh before it was even publicly screened
it it can at the cannon film festival in
1994. um we saw like this sneak
screening off the quaset late at night
and [ __ ] that for was for
invitation only and i remember by the
end of the screening i was like i have
to do another draft of dogma immediately
like this guy just [ __ ] changed the
game and [ __ ] so yeah i you know i i'm a
big fan
that's fair
big point
um okay all right so this is my last one
it was my favorite comment of the night
we've been talking about sandman for
five or six minutes and jackie
somebody somebody should just put
predator versus victor garber in chat
amazing anyway back to you sir uh so
jackie treehorn just a little bit into
the sandman discussion goes oh i thought
you guys were talking about sandman from
spiderman
wow i mean to be fair
to be fair that's what i honestly felt a
little bit of when i was watching the
sandman like when i watched the marvel
movies and i'm like oh my god i read
this story when i was a kid oh my god i
know what's going to happen next oh my
god this character is this person i had
the same [ __ ] things going on with
sandman it was just a more high brow
version of that like where i'm like oh
my god i remember every one of these oh
my god he's about he's she's talking
about hob oh my god they're doing the
whole hob [ __ ] thing like it it was
it was very much like uh the exp now i
got to be careful because somebody will
write an article kevin smith
[ __ ] compares sandman to marvel and
then i'm gonna get beat up by film
twitter i'm just saying
there was a similar
sense of discovery
that
is that okay with that will that
i think so
uh
discovery yeah i'm certainly not saying
the two are comparable by any stretch of
the imagination but there was a sense of
me as the person who's read all these
stories many years ago watching these
stories play out
had you know i have the same
experience when i watch most marvel
movies anyway
it doesn't matter how much i clarified
the headline is just gonna be
yes one day i'm gonna stop doing this
show it's gonna be that simple and
that's not a threat
i'm just saying it's gonna i'm gonna get
to a place where i'm like i can't say
anything without [ __ ] getting
a click-baity screaming headline and
[ __ ] and then getting a bunch of angry
people showing up on my twitter feed
being like
you don't speak for the entire latin
community and i was like i i didn't say
that i did i i i
i i i do feel as if it's going to be my
sort of matt damon slash ben affleck
moment when i show up to your house
with uh you know the dunkin coffee ready
to go to work and i knock on your door
and i open up the zoom and kev she's not
there
deep cuts wonderful [ __ ] reference
and did you get a private smile to
yourself and then just go the [ __ ]
kid did it all right
then you turn around to like ralph and
jay
and andy mccall for scott moshe like
he's not here i don't know what happened
and [ __ ] like you know moshe jumps in
the shotgun seat
oh my god now that's some deep cuts
wonderful deep cuts references took me
right back to 1997 right there
um
okay
uh you got any questions
uh yeah first question i like this one
uh
based on sandman discussion jason brown
wanted to know
if there's a q a i'd like to ask
each of mark and kevin's favorite dream
that you can remember
favorite dream wow what a great [ __ ]
question i mean in honor of the sandman
um
shout out to russell cook on chat who
just wrote predator versus gabo cabo
gabo gabo
that's
people are [ __ ] wonderfully funny um
you got one mark that you remember
i i rarely remember my dreams
um to the point where i'm occasionally
not sure that i have them um
although everybody hated everybody does
dream and so i 100 get it but i'm not
i'm not like a dream journaler
i don't i don't wake up and scribble
down whatever i can remember um
i'd like to say that my favorite dream
probably involved titties but
um
that would just be a guess
i don't know man i don't have one
i don't think i have one um i have like
least favorite dreams
i i do remember there is a dream i
remember and i had it when i like first
moved to la
um
that i was in a ralph's parking lot in
my car
and and it was probably because i had
just seen heat
and i'm in my car in the supermarket and
then somebody with a gun is stalking the
parking lot
and i'm hiding in like the sort of the
back seat as far down as you can
possibly get
and i just hear gunshots off in the
distance and then i see like i'm like
down here like looking up at the window
and then i see the guy walk by
and then i see him tap the barrel of the
gun on the window and then he aims the
gun at me as i'm cowering in the back of
my car and then he fires and then i wake
up
that is the most vivid dream that i've
ever had that i still remember and i
must have had that dream at this point
now like 15 years ago
and you only once
yeah it's not like i've had that dream a
lot of times i've only abraham at once
but i think it was one of those like i'm
in la i was by myself at the time living
in a stranger's apartment and all of the
weird swirl of emotions and fears and
trepidations about
um
being away from everything and everyone
and that's how it manifested with me
getting
gunned down in a ralph park a lot
so the opposite of what you asked for
young camper but uh that's what i got
from the dream diary
i um
the dream that i have the recurring
dream that i have had um and i guess it
is a nightmare
um
is a plane crash
um i fly a lot more than i ever intended
to fly in my [ __ ] life um you know
i would say the average person flies
what
four times a year maybe
um i fly you know sometimes four times a
[ __ ] week and [ __ ] so i spent a lot
of time on planes and
i have a dream a recurring dream about
plane
like coming in for a landing but always
through a cityscape generally i guess we
it's an emergency of some sort
and it's always us like soaring straight
at buildings but then doing this [ __ ] to
get between the buildings
which you know
i don't think 747s are really meant to
do [ __ ] barrel rolls or side flips or
anything like that
and uh invariably it leads to a crash
and
um
i never see the end of the
dream so i
i feel like i'm probably gonna
die in a plane crash like the amount
that i've
had dreams about and stuff and um
you know it's irritating to die
because of somebody else when you're not
in control uh you know i'm sure this
goes for most people but as a director
like i've spent most of my life
being in control of a situation of
what's going on of my future
um
when you're in a plane that somebody
else is flying and [ __ ] like you're
crashing it is
death beyond your control
like you know if i'm driving a car and
another car hits me
at least i was in control of the car i
had a chance to get away from death and
i didn't escape the chance so be it when
you're you know passenger and somebody
else is playing and stuff
i've i've had to learn over the years
over [ __ ] over three dec almost three
decades of [ __ ] traveling to just
once i step into the tube it's not up to
me anymore irritates would irritate the
[ __ ] out of me dying that way because
i'm like god damn it
like i ain't in control of this this is
somebody else is [ __ ] doing
but you know i i kind of
just every time my plane door closes i'm
like
it's on them now and nothing i could do
not a damn [ __ ] thing i could do if
something goes wrong and [ __ ] so that is
the plane dream is my only recurring
dream in life
i've had it's not the same exact dream
every time it's not the same exact
flight but it is the same scenario of me
on a commercial airliner heading out of
[ __ ] cityscape and then the plane
having to do
this between buildings but us not
necessarily making it
but never remembering
the crash
like i guess it's kind of like the
sopranos where the screen just goes
black and everybody calls the cable
operator going what the [ __ ] happened
um
yeah but i don't have a
try and think if i have a great dream
that i loved i mean this is going to
sound gross and i probably shouldn't say
it out loud because somebody will
turn into some [ __ ] horrible click
bait headline but holy [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ] giant bug that just came in this
house
uh
here talk i got to take this bug out of
here
what is it
i don't know he's trying to get in my
can yeah jump in that can buddy go ahead
is it a is it a flying bug is it a
spider bug
it looks like he's a flying bug looks
like he just flew the [ __ ] in here and
he's crawling into my can thank god i
saw it happen otherwise i would have
taken a drink out of it oh that's a
nightmare yes talk amongst yourself no
he's coming back out of the can mark
he came right the [ __ ] back out of the
can this is drinking
if you think that i'm a [ __ ] like uh
crybaby when it comes to like you know
movies that i like on the internet
oh my god i i [ __ ] don't like i'm not
a bug guy at all but i can't kill him as
well i spent a lot of time this guy's
[ __ ] huge he's going back in the can
where's casper van dean
yeah is it a is it a oh [ __ ] man that's
what it looks like it looks like one of
them and [ __ ]
i mean it looks like a roach but it's
too [ __ ] big and it just flew here
out of nowhere do roaches
yeah that surprised the [ __ ] out of me
when i first encountered a flying roach
i mean how the [ __ ] did he get in
because of the open door what the [ __ ]
all right now he's the can i'm gonna
cover the can all right
all right you got it okay well yeah he's
[ __ ] trapped in the can you guys talk
amongst yourselves i'll be right back
okay good luck
i'll share i'll share i've got two
dreams
one is the exact same dream you have
mark except
i'm in a toys r us
getting shot
wow like i'm hiding in a toys r us
uh
so i guess it's probably better because
if you're gonna get shot i'd rather be
at toys r us but i guess
i mean toys r us doesn't exist so i
won't die that way
i mean i was also like thoroughly
uncomfortable i feel at the you know in
the bottom of the back seat of my car
hiding in a in like the wheel well or
whatever
whereas at least you're surrounded by
toys yeah oh
how you doing
that that really [ __ ] me up man
like that thing was huge
huge
and he walked into my [ __ ] my can of
liquid death
that's a new cannon yes
no this is another can i i i might not
drink [ __ ] anything from a can ever
again after what i just [ __ ] up
i had two cans here and he walked into
the [ __ ] empty one and [ __ ]
but that he it was he landed with a thud
like i [ __ ] heard [ __ ] and i looked
over and he was huge
[ __ ] huge
i like
i don't get it like i gotta you know
i got a real clean house man but like
[ __ ] living in los angeles
like when you live in the hills we live
in the [ __ ] hills
we get more [ __ ] vermin and varmints
than i ever had in new jersey
i had never seen a [ __ ]
uh rat in my life until i [ __ ] moved
to california and [ __ ]
like they all come for the pool water
and [ __ ] and you're like what the [ __ ]
and this damn thing that went out there
damn skippy look like a roach but we
ain't got roaches so
unless we do and i don't know about it
but how the [ __ ] would that happen like
i remember looking when i was when i was
looking to buy a house during the
pandemic we went to go see a house
up in porter ranch which if you know
anything about the l.a geography it's on
the north side of the valley and this
house was putting up against like
the rolling hills of like you know used
to be a savannah and so there was just
wild land behind it
and i was like oh so you know
what what's the the vernon situation
like oh well
you might get a scorpion
you know you might get a black widow you
might get a snake or two i was like we
are not buying this house but i am sorry
but i am i am a i'm a
i'm a refined gentleman
i'm a dazzling urbanite i can't be
living in a house that has [ __ ]
scorpions rolling in
we have
we have
so many black widows up by me i'm
basically porter ranch but
east like the the easterly
side of the city but that far north up
against the hills uh the mountains there
and
jen hates
like true arachnophobia
and i was like oh yeah they're black
widows all over the place she's like no
they're not i was like if we walk from
our driveway three houses down and back
i bet you we count more than a hundred
black widows
she's like no way i was like okay let's
go do it
we stopped counting at a hundred and
twenty
big black widows
yeah nope
and then
i didn't i haven't really told anybody
but uh we have tons of coyotes
and
happy ending to this story i'll preface
it with that i got back from comic con
saturday night
and was sitting on the sofa and megan
who runs the bar and jen were going over
our harry potter event stuff
and we heard a yelp
and a coyote had come
into our front yard right up to the
house and grabbed my dog i have a little
pug 18 year old pug
grabbed the pug
from
who had just gone outside to get a drink
of water and took off down the street i
heard the yelp i ran down the street
shouting and clapping
and found my dog with a couple
superficial cuts on the back of her neck
in the middle of the road
at midnight after our our show at
comic-con
and like carried her back in it was
and then jen
went on our
security cameras and i watched the whole
thing happen
on security camera
it is
insane so if you don't want to be around
creatures don't move north
you sound like a santa monica guy
[Laughter]
that's horrifying oh my god dude
oh my god how's it going now she's
totally fine
she literally on camera i mean she's
such a she's like shacky she's like old
and feisty and like just
just
tough
so the coyote's carrying her down our
driveway
and she's wiggling and drops and instead
of running away she turns and she's deaf
and blind turns around and attacks the
coyote
there's like 20 pound pug going after
this like 40 50 pound coyote
little dogs are just
[ __ ] you never find anything as brave
as the little ass dog man they just
think
they all got napoleon complexes they're
all just like i could take that [ __ ]
it's like no you can't you start doing
donuts in the cul-de-sac and just
peel out right through
yeah it was crazy uh
somebody uh on in chat was just like hey
man that [ __ ] bug could have had kids
no [ __ ] that's why i didn't kill it i
just captured it in the can
took it outside
released it but now
i'm starting to think like what if this
[ __ ] just comes back in under the door
i always got a taste for man flesh
what is he doing in here what are they
doing in here somebody on chat said that
it's too hot outside so [ __ ] nature's
trying to get inside to the air
conditioning that ain't true is it we um
it could be water
it could be
it's going for my [ __ ] can we have
stairs it's like go upstairs drink the
pool [ __ ]
we had um we got a little braggy i don't
want there to be a click baby headlines
smith brags about pool
tells roaches to [ __ ] you know let
him eat cake or whatever the [ __ ] i'm
just saying
if he's thirsty
there's a whole pool up there
somebody in there
we got back from uh went on vacation for
fourth of july when we got back
we found a couple big dead roaches at
the house and jen was like nuh uh
and she called the pest control people
and
they said oh you don't need to worry
about the big cockroaches it's the
little ones the big ones come up a drain
or
a sink pipe or something like that
looking for water
and then typically they if you see them
dead they've
couldn't find water and they dehydrated
and died they're like the little ones
are the ones that get into your house
and lay eggs and spread like crazy
so it could just be it was a thirsty bug
yeah look i'll buy that because a he was
like standing within smashing proximity
to me
like you know this bug must have been so
[ __ ] thirsty he's like i don't give a
[ __ ]
the dude's sitting right there i'm going
for his drink like if i was a piece of
[ __ ]
or a rational human being
i could have [ __ ] killed that thing
so goddamn easily and stuff but because
i got a tender heart thanks mom
i look up she's in florida not not in
heaven
um
you know i can't [ __ ] kill the
goddamn bug i gotta capture it and take
it outside release it and [ __ ]
it's not in my [ __ ] dna even though
you know
i get real shitty and territorial when
things are here shouldn't be here man
like
[ __ ] yeah you don't belong here this
ain't this ain't for you and then you
realize
like nobody told them that
right
so what i'm saying it's not like one day
everybody sat all the [ __ ] bugs and
animals down and said this is where you
don't [ __ ] go
so
i you know [ __ ] had to be
thirsty as [ __ ] to get this close and
like just walk into a can that's within
reach and [ __ ] so
i i wish him luck but not in this house
you got to give him a warning
so hey don't come in
i took him out alive he left i mean look
you you don't know how much i've talked
about it before but i spend an
inordinate amount of time
using like business cards people give me
business cards all the time i keep them
on my desk because
during the summer the ants come out
like we live you got to remember it
sounds so [ __ ] like where do you live
in a garbage pit we live built into a
mountain
so my house is literally built into the
[ __ ] earth itself so you can't be all
shitty when
you know [ __ ] things that live in the
earth are like say what's this all about
and start coming in the house so i get
ants all the time and stuff particularly
in the summertime but like on my desk
they'll come up like one two three at a
time or some say [ __ ]
scouting
but i don't kill them and [ __ ] i take
the business card and i let them walk on
to it and then i turn around and put
them down on the [ __ ] floor and i
always wonder what goes through their
heads because they're like i'm in a
completely different [ __ ] place man
it took me
the equivalent of a week to get up to
the and now i'm [ __ ] back down where
i was like i'm alive
but [ __ ] like it must be like when
humans get abducted by aliens and [ __ ]
something just bigger i'm not cattle
prodding up its ass but like i must [ __ ]
with their minds by bringing them from
here
and putting them down there and [ __ ] or
it's like andy mcelfir says they don't
think like humans they're just like food
life that's it and they don't think
about you at all
i don't know i like to anthropomorphize
everything in my life
so we answer your dream question sir
yes
nightmare just [ __ ] happened uh my
dream
i don't remember i don't really
this is gonna sound gross i think this
is the point i was about to make
but like i don't spend a lot of time
sleeping and or dreaming because
uh to borrow from uh
uh elliott
um or no i'm sorry tomorrow from [ __ ]
lawrence um
you know it's vanity like you know
dreaming is you know you wake to find it
was but vanity
i i live a life and this is the gross
part i live a life where like
my waking hours are way more interesting
than my dreams because i can make my
dreams come true because my dreams are
all lame and small i don't dream about
like i take over the [ __ ] kingdom of
candyland and [ __ ] no i dream about like
making clerks three i can make that
happen i keep my dreams manageable but i
don't get [ __ ] done while i'm sleeping
you know it's just like
[ __ ] forced to watch a movie that i
didn't even sign up for and [ __ ] i'd
much rather be awake because when i'm
awake then i can enact
so you know bring him to life and [ __ ]
so i i guess it's a cop out of an answer
but i did direct cop out
nice job thank you
i'll give you my quick dream that's
since
we want to share we we should answer at
least one non-nightmare is
my recurring dream is like i'm sitting
on the sofa and i want to change the
channel
and i reach for the remote and it will
jump to my hand and i sit there and i go
it actually finally [ __ ] happened
like i have the force like usually i
dream about this
and i hope that it will like in my dream
i'm like you're not dreaming this time
you actually have the force
and it's always to get the remote off
the table to change the channel so
my my in in dreams whenever i'm forced
into a fight situation um i'm
so slow
like like you know [ __ ] matrix slow
well i'll go to throw a punch and then
it's like
this and by the time it connects it's
just that it doesn't even hurt or do
anything
in my dreams i punch very weakly but
i'll be honest with you i think that
would be the case in real life as well
all right all right uh josh alferez uh
says if there was a fat man beyond toy
line what accessories would mark and kev
figures come with what would be the
alternate outfits and who would be in
the line
what's the chase figure
um well it's a lot of questions all
right so it's uh what is it fat man
beyond
fat man be on toy line so who who are
the first five figures or whatever in
the toy line
and who's the chase figure
the first five figures
are
uh obviously me
mark and banff man
then
uh andrew is the chase figure
nice
and
i don't even think we get
five i think we get four
at the first line and maybe the only
line
we don't have like a department full of
wacky characters this is not like a
morning show in the 80s or something
it's just really the four of us and
and uh don't you know who's the chase
figure the small chip is the chase
figure that's good yeah that's true fair
enough they've been on the pod a couple
times
again well hosted co-hosted
line two like the second wave could be
like dark nate like cat ears
wow the audience
good idea we turn that's how we get four
more figures out of this [ __ ] damn
eyes
jamie shannon [ __ ] nate
[ __ ]
i wonder if we could license like our
best guests too like could we get
um
could we get uh
like um
oh his name just left me
rick baker like could we have rick baker
like zack stench was he was a really
great guest yeah
zach too
yeah man would be like the simpsons
where they did like all the guest stars
and [ __ ] eventually not all of them but
a bunch in that line of figures they did
you have two playsets you have the bar
playset and you have the album playset
that's true man [ __ ] show playset
itself and then the pre-show [ __ ] the
green alleyway
that's how you get the
alternate one like the alternate kev
clothing like the non uh like the jersey
kev comes with the bar
but like the
the
uh
roosevelt's kev comes with the alley and
like mark has the like be humble at the
bar
but then like in the alley it's like
remember that time robocop shot that
dude in the dick shirt
don't forget if the line keeps going you
know who's the fourth figure in line two
brett deacon
oh yeah
uh because that means we could also do a
40x screening room playset
nice where we all go see [ __ ] 4dx
movies and the you know you put
batteries in the chairs and they vibrate
yeah and then like the third line we can
do a black man beyond line so we can
have like phil lamar and katy sakhoff
and trisha
malcolm barrett
wow
wow man you did it let's [ __ ] come
and tell you yeah we got we got some
toys here kids i mean thing is we just
don't have a big enough audience to
support it
but uh [ __ ] what a great question
that gives me a prize
all right
uh and then the last was russell cook
who also got a shout out earlier for a
nice comment
uh he said like pray which franchise
or character would you like to see set
in a different time period
oh
i'm batman i would love to see gotham by
gaslight
watch tomorrow the headline is smith
[ __ ]
threatens
stamps his feet like a child
over the back of gotham by gaslight
uh i would love to see gotham by
gaslight
you know batman in any era
like
almost any era i don't need
you got a period of history you're just
like you don't give a [ __ ] about
like
1200s
i don't care
dark ages of [ __ ] skip batman in the
1200s
cave batman
then you can jump ahead to like
jack the ripper back man [ __ ]
revolutionary war batman world war one
batman world war ii batman
um
what was the question
i really got lost
name batman's once i got to world war ii
batman i was like what the [ __ ] are we
talking about
a character you'd like to drop in
another time right right good point all
right so i was i was right i was on the
money with all those batmans
i was like i think i'm just saying you
know sometimes you say a word so many
times it loses meaning and relevance
like batman
i batman the batman away
um yeah i can see batman
i'll see him in any era um who else who
else would i like to see
we got some wolverine that way
in like some of those
marvel movie like origins movies
and in the comics too
um
you know
i don't even know what to say anymore
unless people [ __ ] tear me a new one
online and [ __ ] put it under a
clickbait headline but
you know
jesus
we always see him in one era
let's see him in other times
yeah just [ __ ] how would he how would
he dress during the french renaissance
like
let's see jesus through history it's not
second year this
we only see him in like
33 a.d
it's very specific
and not one of my favorite time periods
like
you know they don't even have a video
game set then so
i feel like
i feel like you bring them into the
modern age you can put them in the old
west
i guarantee you man i've been to like
religious bookstores where you could buy
paintings or pictures of jesus
doing any number of things i bought one
of him playing hockey with kids
he gets around
so you know all i'm saying is like all
right
what if he was a shogun
stuff like that
what if you know he was uh what's that
stuff uh
um
steampunk what if steve what if he was
in the steampunk error stuff like you
know
like dear marvel
i'm kevin smith i'd like to pitch you a
new what if series but it's always what
if and jesus
what if jesus was captain america
one of the most popular character you
know figures of of human history i think
he could be shuffled into other
franchises yeah what if jesus was an
x-man
look i just want to say for the record i
did not say that
don't clickbait me with oh this is it
i will say this though
um
did you see the growing movement
for um uh
um
who should play professor x next
i am i'm 100
in the uh in the giancarlo esposito camp
i saw him at a con i forget with one of
the most not the one in uh
not san diego but the one i went to
before san diego or maybe after san
diego yeah maybe it was when i went to
durham
yeah before i went to raleigh before i
went to
uh jersey for my birthday and uh i saw
him there you know i run into him at
cons all the time and i i of course love
his
current body of work and i'm so happy
that like he's [ __ ] working like
crazy lately but i go way back to spike
lee country with giancarlo esposito and
you know to do the right thing bugging
out and and then
into uh mo better blues and so forth and
so on
so like um
he was passing by and i always like kid
him about being the [ __ ] most
well-dressed person at [ __ ] comic con
he's always looks like the cover of
[ __ ] gq and [ __ ]
but i said hey man i stopped him as he
was pissed about i said hey man
i saw something today that like i
thought was brilliant
is it true like are they talking to you
at all
about professor x in the new x universe
and he goes no but i'm willing that into
existence i was like i'm with you i
think i could see it like it's so
perfect and could you imagine like from
bugging out to professor x
um
is that is it
is it a possibility
i mean
he he's gone on the record not just to
you with the back halls of convention
but he's come out and said like a
he has met with marvel was his quote um
and he wants to play professor x
um
whether or not it happens for real who
the [ __ ] knows but
i'm here for it i'm 100 here for it you
know i think that that as we keep having
conversations about magneto and and
especially can magneto still be a
holocaust survivor is the conversation
that i've seen have been the most given
that by the time this happens
a holocaust survivor would have to be if
they aged normally
like 90 years old
to then be your magneto it's like so
but i do think it's important that
there are but so many jewish characters
in these things and to keep that part of
his origins intact
feels important to me as it does i'm
sure to lots of jewish readers of marvel
comics
um so you can play something like
the powers keep the iron in his blood
young because he could magnify whatever
the [ __ ] magneto powers can make that
happen
or there's time travel whatever it is
but like
professor x can be anybody
you know all professor x needs to do is
be rich and have a house and a
wheelchair
um and maybe not even all those things
at once
and so there's something very
interesting about gin carlo
as a you know biracial person of black
and italian descent um
having a conversation about
um
subjugation
with a holocaust survivor in whatever
period they decide to send his ex
i'm [ __ ] here for it give it to me
um
yeah somebody in in chat uber just said
culture hand-me-downs i don't think it's
really that it's just that's he's a
great actor
that's a cool role that like i could see
that dude [ __ ] crushing um oh yeah
and i'd like to see him play a hero
you know we always
kind of always playing you
know because he's so [ __ ] good at it
but
still
god he's amazing in the boys
um
oh so yes um what what character would i
like to see drop in a different time
period i would like to see like 1899
robocop
like give me the steampunk like held
together by science
in you know the in the the knickerbocker
hospital operated on by algernon edwards
um
you know yeah give me the the the new
york bowery policeman who gets shot and
bludgeoned and beat the [ __ ] out of that
he has to bring back
to to life with medicine and science and
metal and gears and [ __ ] to go back onto
the beat and work
um
yeah i would i would [ __ ] watch that
um
yeah so again i think we answered all
the
questions
man i think we hit them is that three
have we answered
questions three and that's three as we
as we increased into the three hour and
thirty minutes
um
chat once again kids uh you made it hard
to pay attention to the show all the
time because you're all so entertaining
and
people say some really
funny [ __ ] the
the
headlines continue the
the uh kate van dyke wrote kevin smith
saves cockroaches lives the audacity to
assist a living creatively creature
the one that killed me that i i had to
mute the mic for was boujee smith kicked
neighborhood roaches out of hollywood
home
i mean
you know i i guess i don't remember ever
having this thought but i guess at some
point in my life i was like boy i wish i
was famous
and
i'm here to tell you
it's not all it's cracked up to be
[Music]
it's a real target on your back
especially because i don't have like
that cool ass fame that like opens doors
and [ __ ] like that like in order to go
to show west i had to buy a whole ass
movie theater
you just call the guy
can i come to show west oh good lord i'm
a hustler i'm a worker kids i don't know
what to tell you speaking of working i'm
working this weekend man are you in
boston are you in massachusetts well
come to boston for fan expo boston i'm
going to be there with j muse we're
going to take pictures um we're going to
take pictures with the the cast of
clerks brian jeff going to be there
trevor
uh then we're going to sign stuff and
then at night me and jay are doing jay
and silent bob get older what married
times they'll be
uh tickets at seasmod.com and then the
weekend not the weekend after that the
other weekend after that
is fan expo canada man
with uh uh up in toronto same
same thing i'll be going up there with
jay and
taking pictures doing jay and sam bob
goodall hello
are you okay
no
um
and uh
so uh you know tickets for that at
seaspot.com and do not forget
uh clerks3 kids
uh not only am i touring it
clerk's three of the convenience store
you could watch it with me and we're
adding dates all the time like we just
added
atlanta
orlando tampa
charlotte charleston and durham
uh they go on sale now if you're a
member of that kevin smith club or they
go on sale friday for everybody else on
friday we're going to have an
announcement
about the fathom events screenings which
is really great news uh but uh tickets
for that if you can't see the movie with
me on tour
on the convenience store you can just
see it in the fathom events theater
participating theater near you uh all
the tickets the trailers the times
whatever available clerks three uh dot
movie thank you to everybody who's been
buying
[ __ ] in advance like you know we went to
big venues this time around and so one
by one they're starting to
drop and sell out we're getting ads
second shows um
the the the folks at fathom were very
excited about pre-sales thus far and
that's what friday's thing will be about
so thank you kids like uh it means the
world to me that people give a [ __ ] that
clerks three is coming uh i have only to
let you down now which if i know kevin
smith he sure will sooner or later
but uh thank you for uh the support man
it's uh
shaping everything's shaping up real
nicely for a wonderful fall right now
we've got dates touring dates from
september 4th we start in red bank new
jersey
and i think like right now we're booked
all the way up to
thanksgiving so i'm gonna be out there
if you don't see your city yet
it's coming
it's coming kids clerks three dot movie
you got anything you want to promote
mark
um
let's see i'm i'm i'm going to a couple
of cons not nearly as many as you are
but i'm at the memphis comic con in
september the 24th and 25th
um where i'll be signing and maybe on a
panel or two i don't know if i'm
podcasting or not they haven't told me
they wanted me to do that
uh unclear i'm at uh thought bubble
uk in the in in the good old united
kingdom
november
i think it's 11 12 13 is that weekend
and then in december i'm at the galaxy
con columbus where i did just see that a
certain kevin smith was also going to be
a guest of the galaxy con columbus when
is that that is december uh second third
and fourth
well i'll find out because i believe the
smod castle film festival is happening
right around then as well
but uh i'm sure if you're gonna be there
maybe i will be there as well can i uh
where else you gonna be um that that is
about it i will be at d23
but i'm not sure if i can say why
uh andrew rose and chat had a headline
nerd coward shames new jersey by
cowering from west coast bug
oh good lord
oh good lord
um
kids did you have a good time
i know i did
if you [ __ ] did i mean the show was
three hours and changed three and a half
hours we went
tonight lord um yeah we gotta thank
banff man for making this happen
he brings us all together come together
right now i'm sure that's not expensive
to sing
banff man we thank you oh bamf man we
love you thank you for making the show
happen that was a little bit of uh
of texas chainsaw massacre too right
there just takes
uh but if you like to show it all kids
it's it's because of the other guy uh
the one who doesn't
you know [ __ ] say click baby [ __ ] uh
the guy who loves everything and
everybody indeed uh marvelous mark
bernard and everybody thank you mr smith
and that
is uh fat man
beyond for this week kids uh tune in
next time
oh no that is fat man beyond for this
week i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard
tune in next time same fat time same fat
channel
smodcast.com or
youtube.com
jeff's kiss everybody
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith